A GOOD AFTERNOON. I AM CALLING
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON PORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT TO
ORDER. THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE TODAY A SPECIAL THANKS TO
KILEY FROM FROM MY OFFICE TO
PUT A LOT OF THIS IF NOT ALMOST
ALL OF IT TOGETHER AND THIS ALL
CAME ABOUT THROUGH A
CONVERSATION WITH- MICHELLE
GRUBS I DON'T KNOW SHE'S HERE.
NO SHE MADE A PLANE THIS
MORNING AND WAS VERY LONG AT
THE AIRPORT I KNOW THAT BUT
EITHER WAY- SO I WANT I WANT TO
THANK THOSE TO SPECIFICALLY BUT
ALSO EVERYONE IS HERE TODAY-
THANK YOU- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
I REPRESENT THE PORTS OF LONG
BEACH AND LOS ANGELES UP HERE.
BUT THE TENTACLES OF THE PORTS
GO FAR BEYOND THAT ONE THING
I'M A I OFTEN SAY APPEARS OR
SUPPORT IN EVERY DISTRICT.
EVERY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVERY
STATE SENATOR RELIES. ON THE
PORTS. BE IT TO MOVE THE GOODS
OUT OF THEIR DISTRICT OR TO
MOVE GOODS IN TO THEIR
DISTRICTS SO AGAIN. OTHER PORTS
ARE ARE KEY TO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY- THE EMPLOYEE OVER HALF
A MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
GENERATE OVER NINE BILLION IN
STATE AND LOCAL. ATTACK REVENUE
EACH YEAR. AND THE ON THEIR
ECONOMIC IMPACT PORTS ARE ALSO
LEADING THE WORLD IN
ENVIRONMENTAL INNOVATION. I
REMEMBER A FEW YEARS BACK I WAS
GOING TO THE PORT OF DUBLIN-
AND- IN AS YOU ENTER THE PORTER
DUBLIN SAID THE GREEN PART OF
DUBLIN WOULDN'T SAY THE GREEN
PORT OF DUBLIN BECAUSE THE PORT.
WAS IN IRELAND CAME MY PEOPLE
BUT I'M- IT SAID THE GREEN PORT
OF IRELAND. BECAUSE THAT PART
WAS GOING GREEN. AND THAT ALL
STARTED IN LONG BEACH IN THE
PORTS OF LOS ANGELES. HAS GROWN
INTO REALLY- A WORLDWIDE CALL-
TO GREEN IN OUR OUR PORTS BUT I
WAS IN THE PORT CITY TO GO
GREEN BUT THEY NEED TO MAKE
GREEN. WELL THEY GO GREEN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE INTEGRAL TO
OUR ECONOMY THERE CERTAINLY ARE
INTEGRAL TO MY DISTRICT. AND SO
ALL ALL OF THAT IS. SO OVER THE
PAST DECADE THE PORTS TO AND
FREEDOM TO MOVE AN INDUSTRY AS
HELP ACHIEVE MAJOR AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS. OF THAT IS TRUE
THERE IS MUCH CLEANER. THERE AT
THE AT THE MISSIONS ARE MUCH
REDUCE TO WE HAVE MORE TO DO
YES BUT- SOMEONE SAY THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT IT IS KIND OF
BEEN. PULLED OFF THE TREE BUT I
WOULD SAY WHEN THAT STARTED
THAT WASN'T LOW HANGING FRUIT
FOR THOSE OF US WHO LIVED
THROUGH THOSE. EXPERIENCES IN
THE THEN AGAIN THE WORK IS NOT
DONE YET WE HAVE MORE TO DO. SO
TODAY I KNOW SENATOR LOW-
LEANING GONZALEZ IS GOING TO
COME IN- SHE'S AT LEAST ON THE
SENATE FLOOR SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD INSTEAD OF WAITING- WE'RE
GO HEAD FOR SEE BECAUSE I KNOW
PEOPLE OF SCHEDULES THEY HAVE
COMMITMENTS. AND COMMITTED TO
BE HERE SO I WANT TO CERTAINLY-
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S TIME
HERE TODAY- I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELOISE REYES. WHO IS FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INLAND
EMPIRE IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE OR TWO JUST SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS. RIGHT YEAH. THANK YOU
MICHAEL DONALD AND HIS OTHER
TODAY'S HEARING WHEN I THINK
ABOUT PORTS I THINK ABOUT LONG
BEACH. AND WE KNOW THAT PORT
LONG BEEN GATEWAYS FOR GLOBAL
TRADE ARE CRITICAL TO ECONOMIES
AROUND THE WORLD. THEY ARE
WITHOUT A DOUBT HUBS OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. BUT THEY'RE
ALSO MAJOR SOURCE ESPECIALLY
FOR MY COMMUNITY MAJOR SOURCE
OF POLLUTION VEHICLE EMISSIONS.
PORTS RELY ON A WIDE RANGE OF
VEHICLES WITH ENGINES WHICH ARE
A SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS. AND
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE GOODS ARRIVING AT THE
SPORTS THEN HAVE TO BE
TRANSPORTED IN OFTEN THESE
GOODS WILL GO THROUGH
COMMUNITIES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE. TO THE CLUSTERS OF
WAREHOUSES AND RAIL YARDS
BEFORE BEING DISTRIBUTED TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. NOT ONLY
THAT BUT THE POLLUTANTS CREATED
LONG BEACH ARE THEN BLOWN EAST
INTO THE NLAND VALLEYS AND ARE
TRAPPED BY THE VALLEY CREATED
BY THE MOUNTAIN RANGES.
COMPOUNDING THE POLLUTION
LEVELS TWO HORRENDOUS LEVELS
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT
THE INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITIES.
WITHOUT A DOUBT MY COMMUNITY.
EXPERIENCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH OUTCOMES ATTRIBUTED TO
THE EXPOSURE THREE MISSIONS
FROM THESE OPERATIONS. I REALLY
APPRECIATE HOWEVER AND I
STARTED ON SUCH A DOWN- BUT WE
REALLY ARE SUFFERING IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT THE
BUSINESS OF THE PORTS. HOW
IMPORTANT THAT THAT BUSINESSES
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE THAT WHILE WE
GO GREEN YOU ALMOST MAKE THE
GREEN. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT I WILL KEEP IN MIND- I
WANT AS A AND THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT I HAVE HAD BOTH WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE PORT AND
WITH OTHERS IN THE TRUCKING
INJURED IT INDUSTRY. AND OTHERS
WITHIN THAT AREA ALL AGREE THAT
WE DO NEED TO DO MORE AND I
WANT YOU TO KNOW I WANT YOU TO
COUNT ON ME AS A PARTNER AS WE
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION. I THINK
IT'S GOOD FOR ALL OF US WHEN WE
DO CONSIDER THE FACT THAT WE DO
NEED TO GO GREEN BUT I WILL
ALWAYS HONOR THE FACT THAT YOU
WILL NEED TO MAKE THE GREEN
WELL WE DO. GO GREEN. SO AS WE
DISCUSSED THE IMPACT OF THE
PORTS ON CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
I HOPE THAT WE WILL ALSO
DISCUSS THE IMPACT OF THE
PORTS. ON CALIFORNIA'S OUR
QUALITY. AND RECOGNIZE THAT
THEIR QUALITY SHOULD BE A PART
OF ANY CONVERSATION WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PORTS. THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU- IN WITH
THAT WILL TURN OR PANELS AND-
COVER PANELS TO DO THEIR BEST
TO HAIR TO THE- TIME. THE OTHER
FACTOR WE HAVE TIME CAN HERE IN
THAT OUR GIVEN A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF MINUTES TO SPEAK IF THEY GET
KIND OF HARD TO THAT NUMBER THE
BE GREATLY HELPFUL SO THAT
EVERYBODY CAN HAVE A CHANCE TO
PARTICIPATE EVERYBODY CAN HAVE
A CHANCE TO HEAR WHAT SOME OF
THE FOLKS HERE TODAY WANT TO
SAY SO OUR FIRST US THE EARLY
CHRISTIAN DICK SHE IS THE MEDIA
PASTURE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
BOARD AUTHORITIES AND SHE IS
FROM PORT WINE AMY AND SO SHE
IS HERE TODAY TO SPEAK WITH US
AND SHARE WITH US THAT OVERVIEW
OF CALIFORNIA SPORTS. SEVENTY
TWO HOUR DRIVE. MISTER CHAIR.
OF MEMBERS OF THE SUDDENLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE SO
GREAT TO BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON
WE HAVE WITH US A WHOLE HOST OF
FOLKS FROM PORTS IN LARGE PART
THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
CHAMPING THE- INAUGURAL PORTS
SAY THAT WE'VE HAD I THINK THAT
WAS NOW WAS IT LAST YEAR TWO
YEARS I CAN'T KEEP COUNT THIS
SPORT IT'S FINE BUT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THERE ARE
NEXT OFFICIAL PORTS STAY IN YOU
CERTAINLY WERE VERY. LOOKING
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER FOR MAKING PORTS THEY
REALITY BRING IS ALL UP HERE
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO SHOWCASE
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND SOME OF
THE WORK OUR MARKS THAT WE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT BEING GREEN
AS WELL SO CHAMPION FOR JOBS IN
OUR ECONOMY. SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO. STOP WITH THE- POWER.
THAT REALLY JUST INTRODUCED YOU
TO THE- SO THAT LANCE. REPORTS
THAT ARE HERE ARE ELEVEN DEEP
WATER PORTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
SO WHO ARE WE- THIS IS WHO WE
ARE SO LONG BEACH LA WHEN HE ME
SAN DIEGO. OAKLAND STOCKTON OF
RICHMOND- HOLDEN BOLTS AND
REDWOOD CITY AND SAN FRANCISCO
AND WE LOOK HERE IN THE NEXT
SLIDE YOU CAN SEE WHERE WE
LIVE. IN SOME OF THE MOST OF.
ST LOCATIONS UP AND DOWN THE
COAST TO CALIFORNIA REALLY
GIVING US A GREAT FOOT PRINT.
TO DO WHAT WE DO BEST WHICH IS
TRADE THIS IS OUR NATION'S
LARGEST TRADE GATEWAY FOR
IMPORTED AND EXPORTED GOOD.
OVER SIXTEEN MILLION CONTAINERS
OF AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS. RAW
MATERIALS AND FINISHED GOODS
LIKE TELEVISIONS TOYS AND MORE.
FLOW IN AND OUT OF CALIFORNIA
PORTS EVERY YEAR. TOUCHING
EVERY CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT IN
THE CONTINENTAL US.
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN COMMERCIAL
PORTS ALSO PROVIDE NON CARGO
RELATED SERVICES AND FACILITIES
LIKE PASSENGER CRUISE AND VERY
SERVICES RESTAURANT AND HOTEL
ACCOMMODATIONS RECREATIONAL
MARINAS PUBLIC WATERFRONT
EVENTS AND TWO DOCKSIDE TOURIST
ATTRACTIONS. ONE THIRD OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY RELIES ON GOODS
MOVEMENT TO FACILITATED BY
CALIFORNIA PORTS SUPPORTING
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIA JOBS
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
IN REVENUE AND NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL STATE TAX
REVENUE. CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
PORTS ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO
MAINTAINING ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE OPERATIONS AND OVER
THE PAST DECADE CALIFORNIA
PORTS HAVE SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCED EMISSIONS ACROSS THE
BOARD BETWEEN FIFTY AND NINETY
PERCENT. CALIFORNIA PORTS ARE
VITAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND OUR INVESTMENT IN MARITIME
INFRASTRUCTURE HELPS TO
CONTINUALLY GROW OUR NATION'S
ECONOMY. FOR MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA PORTS
SERVE YOUR AREA CONTACT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES YOUR MERIT TIME
POLICY RESOURCE. I'M SO THAT'S
JUST A NICE OVERVIEW OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT LEVIN PORTS AND IF I
COULD GET A SHOW OF HANDS WHO
ARE THE PORT STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE ROOM I KNOW WE HAVE. A LOT
OF PEOPLE THE TRAVELED LONG AND
FAR TO GET HERE TO BE WITH US
TODAY SO THANK YOU EVERYBODY
FOR COMING- AND A QUICK NOTE WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US MARTHA MILLER
OF PLATINUM AND JEFF WEISS
VENABLE WHO ARE NEW LEADERSHIP
FOLKS BOOTS ON THE GROUND FOR
KAPUSO HOPEFULLY YOU'RE GOING
TO BE HEARING A LOT OF THEM AS
THEY ARE ARE THOUGHT. IN OUR
INNER VOICE TO OUR AGENDA
FORWARD TO HELP ON THESE POLICY
SHE IS- A COUPLE OTHER QUICK
SLIDES HERE THIS IS WHAT WE DO
I THINK OUR GIRLFRIENDS IN THE
ROOM BUT WE MOVE GOODS RIGHT
30% OF THE EXPORTS COME THROUGH
OUR PORTS SYSTEMS HERE
CALIFORNIA 40% OF THE IMPORT
COME TO OUR POOR COMPLEX.
CLEARLY NOT ON. ARE WE IN EVERY
DOES. OF CAL. BUT WE COULD
ARGUE WERE ALMOST IN EVERY
DISTRICT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA CREATING FIVE
MILLION JOBS- THROUGHOUT OUR
UNITED STATES. NUMBERS YOU
HEARD THEM- JUST RECENTLY FROM
OUR CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HERE BUT IMPRESSIVE
NUMBERS 25% OF CALIFORNIANS GP
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN. THE
WORLD THAT'S A PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE NUMBER AND- YOU
CERTAINLY NEED TO BE BOXING OR
WAIT HERE'S WE MOVE POLICY FORD
IN CALIFORNIA. JUST A QUICK
HIGHLIGHT WE'RE ALSO CRUISE
PORTS IN OUR SYSTEM OF THE
LEVIN PORTS THOSE ARE AND-
COMPLEXES AS WELL IN THAT THEY
BRING A MILLION DOLLARS RIVER
CRUISE SHIP THE COMES INTO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY SO AGAIN JUST
ANOTHER. RESOURCE AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH OUR PORT
COMPLEX IT'S- NUMBERS AGAIN
FIVE MILLION JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- ARE NATIONALLY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THE LA IN
LONG BEACH AND I KNOW THAT ALL
THE PORTS REALLY ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR- OUR OUR
MUTUAL. REGION'S AND WHEN AMY
WITH THE FOURTH LARGEST
EMPLOYER INVENTORY COUNTY SO
WE'RE REALLY A PART OF THE
BACKBONE OF OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES. AND A THIRD OF ALL
CALIFORNIA JOBS- DEPEND ON
PORTS OF THESE ARE PRETTY BIG
NUMBERS AN IMPORTANT TO POLICY
DECISIONS THAT GO ON HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I MENTION THIS
BRIEFLY BEFORE BUT WE ARE THE
LEADERS LITERALLY THE LEADERS
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD- ONLY PUSH
GOT A PLUG A SHIP IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE LEADING THE WAY ON
THAT TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY- AND
AGAIN SEEING. SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS ON THE AIR QUALITY
CRIME AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
BALANCE THOSE. I'M
ENVIRONMENTAL GAINS ALONG WITH
THE COMP GAMES IN HOLDING. ON
TO MARKET SHE- SO WE'RE HERE.
IT PANEL IN A WE HAVE A LOT OF
STATE IN THE ROOM IN THE WHEN
IS THIS IS LIKE ON PORTS AND
FOR SO WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE OUR
IN THE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT HOW
WERE RISING TO THE CHALLENGES
AND THERE WERE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND KIND OF LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN INVEST. IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HOW WE CAN
CREATE A FAIR AND BALANCED
REGULATORY REGIME- IDENTIFIES
SCENT OF SPUR MANDATES AND-
JUST HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION TODAY WITH YOU
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND MAKE STRONG LEADERSHIP
DECISION. SACRIFICE THAT WE
HAVE A QUICK VIDEO I'LL I'LL
SET IT UP MY- CAME SPENCER MY
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS HAPPEN TO
CORNER THE GOVERNOR IN THE
AIRPORT GOTTEN TO SAY HAT SO
WE COUNT ON YOU TO HELP HOLDEN
TO THE FIRE. YOU READY. HERE WE
GO. OUR GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
HERE AND THE TALKING. YOU KNOW
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT I'M TALKING
ABOUT THIS GUY I SEE PORTS. AND
YOU KNOW WE GOTTA PRO SEAPORT
AGENDA THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN BE
PROCEED MORE. IT'S GOT A VESTED.
INTERESTED OUR COMPETITIVENESS
YOU GOT INVEST. IN OUR
INTERNATIONAL. STANDING ME UP
TO CONTEXTUALIZE THE WORLD
AROUND YOU. THEY'RE STEPPING UP
THEIR GAME. WE GOT A STEP UP
BARS. ZERO SUM. I DON'T WANNA
SO THEY COULD GET TOGETHER AND-
THEY GET A SENSE. ELEVATE OUR
COMPETITION. HERE BUT WE WANT
TO TAKE. THAT'S MINE SHE EIGHT
COMMERCE ALL THESE THINGS AND
LOOK FOR THE WORKERS YEAH THE
TO TAKE THANK YOU AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT COUPLE
OUR WITH YOU TO TALK ABOUT
THESE THINGS GREAT THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO THE GROUP OF
RIGHT NOW BE BACK UP TO THE END
THANK YOU VERY THANK I DID NOT
MENTION THE BEGINNING THAT ARE
MILLER- HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL
PUTTING TOGETHER AS WELL SO WE
APPRECIATE HER HELP. WE'VE GOT
A- WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PANEL THE-
IS THE PORTS IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. WELL FIRST
HER FROM MIKE JACOB WHO IS VICE
PRESIDENT. AND GENERAL COUNSEL
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION. AND THE HORROR
HERE FROM CHRISTIAN AUTUMN-
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION CHRIS. AND THEN RAY
FAMILY PRESIDENT INTERNATIONAL
LONG SURE WAREHOUSE UNION
LOCAL. THIRD THE MEN AND WOMEN
ON THE- ON THE WATERFRONT WHO
MOVED THE GOODS ON AND OFF. THE
SHIPS. SO WITH THAT- WILL START
WITH MISTER JACOB WHEN YOU ARE
READY YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- IS THERE IS-
PRETTY YOU HAVING US HERE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR
STAFFS- WORK PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER REALLY APPRECIATE. AND
OF COURSE WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE. TOPICS THERE ARE A LOT
OF OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT
CAN START OFF A HEARING TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE VISITING
PORTS AROUND THE WORLD BUT- YOU
CAN- AND I DON'T THINK I'VE
HEARD TO REPEAT THE SAME PORT.
ONCE BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN THE
START. OF EVERY SHADE- YOUR
INVESTMENT AND- AND EVERYTHING
WITH MAKE OUR SEAPORTS WORK THE
PROJECT THAT- WE DO WANT TO
ADDRESS OUR QUICKLY AND I HAVE
A COUPLE SLIDES AND SPEAK-
RELATIVELY QUICKLY GO THROUGH.
SOME OF OUR THINGS ARE GONNA BE
FAMILIAR WITH- SOME OF THE
NUMBERS ARE A LITTLE BIT NEW.
THESE ARE OLD- SO THE CONTEXT
FOR WHERE WE ARE NOW OBVIOUSLY
IS THE HISTORY OF OUR GROWTH
AND WHAT IT MEANS. SO FROM
NINETEEN NINETY TO TWO THOUSAND
SIX. LA LONG BEACH OAKLAND ALL-
HAD VERY VERY ROBUST AND
PROFOUND CONTINUOUS GROW PATHS.
AND WHEN YOU WERE TO THOUSAND
SIX REGULATOR POLICY GIRL
UNDERWRITER OR REPORT I'M DOING
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING- YOU
PROJECTED OUT NUMBERS THAT LOOK
LIKE THIS THESE ARE FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
SICA'S MOVING MISSION REDUCTION
PLAN TWO THOUSAND SIX LOOKING
AT CLOSE TO. A PER. OF THE WELL.
A LOT MORE CONTAINERS THAN WE
ACTUALLY MOVED SO WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SIX AND- TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS. WERE LA
LONG BEACH OAKLAND. ALL AROUND
50% BELOW WHERE WE PROJECT OUR
TOTAL THROUGHPUT. OF REPRESENTS
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
CONTAINERS THAT WE DID NOT OF.
THREE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- AND
THAT'S REFLECTION OF. NOT JUST
THE SLOWER GLOBAL ECONOMY AND
TRADE BECAUSE IT DID SLOW DOWN
A LITTLE BIT BUT IT'S PRIMARILY
REFLECTION OF THE FACT THAT-
WE'RE LOSING MARKET SHARE. AND
A MACRO LEVEL WYRLEY LOSING
MARKET SHARE. THIS I THINK
PARAPHRASES- WHAT THE GOVERNOR
TOLD CAMP. WE NEED TO BE
REINVESTING IN OUR OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN WE LOSE VOLUME
AT THE SAME TIME WE INCREASE
COSTS WHICH IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING- YOUR COST PER BOX
OBVIOUSLY GOES UP RELATIVE TO
YOUR COMPETITION- AND WHAT
HAPPENS THEN YOUR
COMPETITIVENESS DECREASES YOUR
VOLUMES GO DOWN WHEN YOU'RE
VOLUMES GO DOWN. COST PER BOX
GOES UP IT'S THE SORT OF THE
VIRTUOUS CYCLE REINVESTMENT
THAT WE ALL WANT. WE ALL WANT
MORE CONTAINERS WHICH MAKE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
UPGRADES CHEAPER PER UNIT. AND
WE'VE BEEN MAKING THE MORE
EXPENSIVE PER UNIT. SO AS A
RESULT OF ALL OF THAT IF YOU
LOOK AT THAT THAT CHART THIS
AGAIN FROM NINETEEN NINETY TO
TWO THOUSAND SIX WE WERE
STEADILY GAINING NOT JUST TOTAL
THROUGHPUT BUT ALSO MARKET
SHARE THIS IS A MARKET SHARE
COMPARISON- FOR TOTALLY WEST
CONTAINERS ON THE TOP IN TOTAL
NORTH AMERICAN. PAINTERS ON THE
BOTTOM- POST DOESN'T SIT GIVEN
MOST OF IT BACK SO WE ARE NOT.
MOVING AS MUCH AS OTHER PORTS
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT WILL
BREAK IT DOWN THAT THE GREEN
LINES AT THE BOTTOM ARE. SAN
PEDRO BAY IN OAKLAND- OUR
COMPETITORS SAVANNAH OTHER AT
CANADIAN WEST COAST PORTS-
VIRGINIA NEW YORK NEW JERSEY
THERE ARE GROWING MUCH FASTER.
AND SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT ON A ON A COASTAL BASIS
THIS IS- WE TOOK THIS FROM-
PRESENTATION- I JUST MARKET
SHARE. I'M SORRY I AM AT MY AGE
AS MARKET COMPARISON MARKET
SHARE- AND YOU CAN SEE THE US
WEST COAST COAST MARKET SHARE
THAT GREEN BAR GOING DOWN.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
WE'RE LOSING- OVERALL MARKET
SHARE TO EAST COAST IN A LITTLE
BIT TO THE GULF COAST- SO.
MOVING FORWARD WHEN WE'RE DOING
PLANNING POLICY NOW THIS WAS
TAKEN FROM A DRAFT SEAPORT ANY
EXERCISE AT THE CDC THE BACON
PROVISION BELLMAN COMMISSION
THERE. LOOKING AT- FLOWS FOR
PLANNING WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
BAY AREA IN TERMS OF INVESTMENT
AND NEW SEAPORT INFRASTRUCTURE-
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT OUR OUR
TOTAL COASTAL SHARES OF LOADED
IMPORTS ON PACIFIC WEST THIS IS
NOW BELOW 50% UP AND ALONG FOR
A- YOU KNOW. FIFTH SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PER SO THAT'S DRAMATIC
AND THEN. I THINK TO THAT THE
POINT OF A MADE BY BOTH AND
THAT YOU'RE UP OR- THERE'S A
COST TO LIEU. A SHARE THE
OBVIOUSLY THEIR COSTS THE
KEEPING MARKET SHARE WE- REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES WITH WHAT WE DO
AND WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF
MONEY AND TIME AND ENERGY. TO
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS- A HER
FROM KRISTIN BECAUSE THE TOTAL
OVERALL EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS WE
THINK ARE ARE. SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF. THEIR
SIGNIFICANT- WE'RE ALSO REALLY
PROUD OF THE JOB KNOCKED
BENEFITS THE COME WITH WHAT WE
DO. SO IN LA EVERY FOR
CONTAINERS TO COME THROUGH
THAT'S A JOB. A TWO AND A FIFTY
DOLLAR PER CONTAINER STAY LOW
TAX. THAT IS REAL BENEFIT TO
THE STATE. NOT TO MENTION THE
INDIRECT BENEFITS OF ACTUALLY
ALL OF THE PERSONAL INCOME THAT
COMES FOR CONTAINER AND IN
OAKLAND IT'S THREE JOHN- EVERY
THREE CONTAINERS YOU SEE JOHN.
AND SO WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT
AND WHY AS A MATTER- WELL IT IF
WE'RE NOT COMPETITIVE WE'RE
GONNA GROW SLOWER THAN WE NEED
TO. AND WE WILL BE MISSING OUT
ON ALL THESE BENEFITS WILL BE
MISSING OUT ON STATE IN TAX
REVENUES- WILL BE MISSING OUT
ON JOBS TO BE MISSING A
PERSONAL INCOME. SO THESE WERE
THE LAST COUPLE OF FORECAST
FROM- 200-072-0009 THAT WERE
DONE- IN LA LONG BEACH- AND
THEN WE'RE LOOKING AT A NEW
FORECAST IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. YOU
CAN SEE WHERE WE'RE TRACKING-
WE MISSED OUR OUR TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN FORECASTS WERE MISSING OR
TWO THOUSAND NINE FOUR CATS
WERE TRACKING OUR LOW FOR US.
FOR TOTAL TO EAT SINCE PETER
BACK THAT'S CONCERNING TO US.
THE SAME- TRENDS ARE ARE
PROJECTED FOR PORT OF OAKLAND
YOU CAN START ON WOULD BE.
FANTASTIC IF WE COULD MOVE
SEVEN MILLION TEAS WITH VOCAL
ABOUT MAYES. WELL MICHAEL
ADELINE IT'S GOING TO FIVE
MILLION T. THROUGH TWENTY WHICH
IS A DOT OF TOLL THROUGHPUT
RIGHT NOW ARE ABOUT POINT FIVE
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
DOWN TOWARDS OUT LINE WHICH
DOES NOT EVEN GETS TO THE PLACE
WHERE OUR MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY
THEN COSTS AND PLEASE. THAT
SLOW WINE BOTH HERE IN ST PETER
BAY AND IN OAKLAND DOES NOT
COVER MINIMUM GAIL MINIMUM
ANNUAL GUARANTEED GROWTH. IN
MOST LEASE REVENUE- AT THE
PORTS- AND THAT'S WHERE OUR
MEMBERS ARE ARE MAKING AN
INVESTMENT TOWARDS MAKING SURE
WE'RE REINVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND THEN BEFORE
I TURN OVER TO- CHRISTEN RAY-
JUST. TO POINT OUT SO BE CDC
AND DOING THIS FOR THE PORT OF
OAKLAND THIS IS ON
CONTAINERIZED TRAFFIC WITH YOU
FORECAST. ALSO DID A FORECAST
FOR ROAD ROSE- AND US AT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND BUT IT'S- A-
PART OF. ALBANY JOHN RICHMOND
AND OBVIOUSLY THE FLOWS ARE
VERY SIMILAR AND PART OF SAN
DIEGO ON WINE AMY- YOUR-
CUMULATIVE GROWTH YEAR OVER
YEAR AND BOTH THE SLOW. AND ME
MODERATE WITH. THOSE THREE
FIFTY IS JUST OVER 1% A IT IS
NEW PROJECTED THE EX WERE AND
SO THAT THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
US- AND ON THE DRY BOOKS SIDE
TO EVEN THOUGH THOSE THOSE
CURVES GO WAY UP ON- ON DRY
BULK BUT YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT IS A RELATIVELY SMALL.
PERCENTAGE OF GROWTH OVER TIME-
IF YOU ARE NOT IN A MODERATE OR
HIGH GROWTH ENVIRONMENT- THESE
ARE VERY LOW MARGIN ACTIVITIES
WITH RESPECTABLE GOODS- BUT
THEY ARE GOOD JOBS AGAIN
THEY'RE VERY STUDY ONCE YOU
HAVE A BALK OPERATION AND YOU
CAN KEEP IT. IT'S A IT'S A
STEADY SOURCE OF WORK UP AND
DOWN THE SUPPLY CHAIN. SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE AGAIN WE
ARE GROWING- BECAUSE IT LOWERS
OUR AVERAGE COST PER BOX ARE
MARGINAL COST FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS- IT LEADS TO A
VIRTUOUS CYCLE REINVESTMENT OF
FOR GROWING CONTAINERS WE HAVE
MORE MONEY TO INVEST BOTH- AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE AND FOR
NEW FACILITIES BUT ALSO ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT IS AS WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN NEW EQUIPMENT THAT'S
MORE EXPENSE OVERTIME IN NEW
INTEREST SUPPORT AND WE HAVE TO
GROW UP AND THEN FINALLY
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO. BESIDES
ALL DAY LONG IT'S A TAX
BENEFITS GROWTH WELL. SO THANK
VERY. BRIDGE AND. SO GET
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN OF IN
SIMILAR MEMBER IS THANK YOU FOR
IT MY NAME IS CHRIS OUT OF QUE
TRUCK ASSOCIATION AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK-HERE TODAY I'D LIKE TO ECHO
MISTER JACOBS- APPRECIATION TO
THE CHAIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON- ISSUES RELATED TO THE PORTS
AND GETS MOVEMENT- THE
IMPORTANCE OF CALIFORNIA SEA
PORTS TO OUR ECONOMY IN THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED. FOR A DEPENDENT
INDUSTRIES ARE ESTIMATED TO
ACCOUNT FOR ONE THIRD OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY AND JOBS AND
MUCH OF THIS ACTIVITY FLOWS
DIRECTLY THROUGH REPORTS WITH
SANTA FE PORTS ALONE HANDLING
32% OF AMERICA'S TOTAL CARGO
VOLUMES APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
THOUSAND TRUCKERS SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ALL IN AG
EXPORTS FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
DOZEN FOR ASIAN MARKETS.
IMPORTER MATERIALS THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS IN
EVERYDAY GOOD YOU'RE NOT RELY
UPON. OUR TRUCK BENEFIT THE
FREE FLOWING NOW ON
INTERNATIONAL IT MADE POSSIBLE
BY CALIFORNIA PORTS SO SIX THAT
IS AN ARRAY CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ONE EIGHT MILLION STAGE.
LICENSED OPERATE HERE THESE
TRUCKS ARE OPERATED BY THE
INDUSTRY'S MOST VALUABLE ASSET
THE BACK ON OF THE GOOD
GOVERNMENT SYSTEM THE
PROFESSIONAL TRUCK DRIVER
TRUCKING IS CONSISTENTLY RANKED
ONE OF THE BEST PAYING JOBS FOR
WORKERS WITH COLLEGE EDUCATION
PROVIDING WORKING CLASS
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT ADVANCED
DEGREES A PATHWAY TO CLASS.
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A MAJORITY
MINORITY DRIVER WORK FORCE
ACCORDING TO ET'S LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION CALIFORNIA DRIVER
WORKFORCE 52% LATINO 6% AFRICAN
AMERICAN. 6% A- IN. SUPPORT THE
COMPACT AND AS A BONUS PORTS
SUPPORTS BLUE COLLAR MIDDLE
WERE. ON THE SUSTAINABILITY
FROM. ELF PORTS ARE HOME TO THE
CLEANEST FLEET IN THE COUNTRY.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
ORIGINAL LOS ANGELES AND LONG
BEACH CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAM BAND
PRE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TRUCKS
IT TOOK SEVEN YEARS FOR SEAPORT
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT
THAT SAME REQUIREMENTS. NEARLY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
INVESTED TO UPGRADE TRUCKS
RESULTING IN A 97% REDUCTION
AND DIESEL EMISSIONS THE MOST
OF ANY SECTOR SERVICING THE
PORTS. PORT TRUCKERS HAVE ALSO
BEEN PIONEERS IN THE TESTING OF
ZERO NEAR ZERO MISSION TRUCKS
FOR OVER A DECADE AND CONTINUE
TO PARTNER WITH PORTS
MANUFACTURES AND AGENCIES TO
PUSH THESE TECHNOLOGIES
FORWARD. WITH REGARDS TO THE
COMPETITIVENESS OF CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
AS MR JAKE POINTED OUT THERE
ARE REASONS FOR CONCERN- PORT
DATA INDICATES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MARKET SHARE HAS
SLIPPED TO QUOTE A RECENT
ECONOMIC STUDY COMMISSIONED BY
THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES. IN
BEACH REGARDING TO
DISCRETIONARY CONTAINER VOLUME
AND I QUOTE. NUMBER AFTER THAT
YOU TO KLEIN TRAFFIC MANY WHICH
CAN BE EXPLICITLY. CALPERS THAT
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH ARE UNRELIABLE.
FACTOR CITED BY THE STUDY FALL
INTO ROUGHLY FOUR CATEGORIES.
CONGESTION OR LACK OF
EFFICIENCY- LABOR UNCERTAINTY A
PROLIFERATION OF FEES AND
CALIFORNIA'S STRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS. OUR
MEMBERS PROVIDED US FEEDBACK
FOR THE COMMITTEE ON SOME OF
THESE TOPICS. WHILE MANY
EFFICIENCIES ARE AYE SILENT
PRIVATESTAKEHOLDERS IN AND WE
ARE COLLECTIVELY WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES THERE'S BROAD
SUPPORT FOR STATE AND FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OF
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATED
SUPPORTED SB ONE IN PART TO
PROVIDE DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
TRADE CORRIDORS ENHANCEMENT.
THOSE FUNDS MUST CONTINUE TO BE
INVESTED IN PROJECTS TO
INCREASE SUPPLY CHAIN VELOCITY
RELIABILITY AND THROUGHPUT.
ADDITIONALLY ANY MAJOR NON
MARITIME PROJECTS PLANNED AT OR
NEAR PORT SHOULD BE DESIGNED TO
ENSURE MINIMAL IMPACT SUPPORT
OPERATIONS. ON THE TOPIC OF
FEES ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
THE STAMPEDE REPORTS ARE
CURRENTLY CONSIDERING THE
ADOPTION OF A NEW ROUND OF
CLEAN TRUCK FEES TO SUBSIDIZE
THE PURCHASE OF ZERO AND YEARS
ARE AMERICAN TRUCKS. TO MEET
THEIR GOALS ALL OF HAPPENED A
100% ZERO MISSION- A 100% ZERO
EMISSION PORT TRUCK WE BY THE
YEAR. TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. OUT
FOR TERRORIST WHAT IS ALSO
ANNOUNCED ITS INTENT. TO DOT
NEW REGULATIONS. THE PURCHASE
OF ZERO MISSION PORT TRUCKS AS
EARLY AS NEXT YEAR. THESE NEW
INITIATIVE THEY SHOULD HAVE
MUST BE BALANCED BY THESE
CONSIDERATIONS FIRST.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
NATION'S CLEAN A SPORT TRUCK
FLEET WHICH WILL GET
SIGNIFICANTLY CLEANER DID
ALREADY ADOPTED REGULATIONS.
SECOND THE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
pTRUCKS WERE REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
UTILITY INVESTMENT IN MUST BE
CAREFULLY PLANNED FOR. THIRD
ZERO MISSION TRUCKS AS THEY
STAND TODAY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SERVICE FOR TRUCKING NEEDS FOR
INSTANCE SUPPORT TRUCK. AND
PORTABLE MAY NEED SAME PETER
BAY PORTS MAY NEED TO GET ALL
THE WAY OUT AND ABOUT ERRORS ON
A- FINALLY. ZERO NEAR ZERO
EMISSION TRUCK INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS ARE UNDERFUNDED AND
OVERSUBSCRIBED WE ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK- SUPPORT CLEAN
TRUCK INCENTIVES AND WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO STRENGTHEN
THEM. THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
NEEDED TO ADVANCES TECHNOLOGY I
LIKE TO THINK THAT SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH TO CHEAT
SHARED. ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND I'M I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. FOR FAMILY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTERCHAIR AUDIBLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS RAY FAMILY AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LONG SHORE WAREHOUSE UNION
LOCAL THIRTEEN I'VE GOT A GREAT
HONOR OF APPEARING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND UNION MEMBERS WHO
WORKED TIRELESSLY IN THE PORTS
OF LOS ANGELES ALONG BEATS TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
COMPETITIVE. AS MANY OF THE
OTHER VIEWS THE PROGRESSIVE
LABOR UNION THAT REPRESENTS
LONG FOR WORKERS ALONG THE WEST
COAST WE ARE VERY PROUD OF OUR
LONG HISTORY AND TRACK RECORD
OF ADVOCATING FOR WORKERS'
RIGHTS INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO
WORK IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND
THE RIGHT TO EARN FAIR WAGES
AND BENEFITS TO THAT END THE
I'LL W. SUPPORT SOCIAL
POLITICAL AN EX COP. WORK HARD
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S PORTS
ARE COMPETITIVE WE BELIEVE THE
FIRST AND MAIN WAY IN
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS CAN STAY
COMPETITIVE IS BY MAINTAINING
CREATING JOBS FOR WORKERS- THAT
ALL OF CAL IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA
SPORTS DOING SO IS CRUCIAL FOR
THE HEALTH OF OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
AND THE ECONOMY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BY IN PART BY
RETAINING THE WORK FORCE AND
INVESTED IN TRAINING RECENTLY
THERE HAS BEEN AN OVERALL DID
DEPRIEST IN CARGO COMING
THROUGH OUR NATION'S PORTS DUE
IN LARGE PART TO THE ARE TRUMP
ADMINSTRATION'S UPS. THESE
HOWEVER THIS WE CONTINUE SEE
CARGO FLOWING THROUGH OUR PORTS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES SAID IN A NEW ALL.
TIME CARGO RECORD BY MOVING
MORE THAN MORE CARGO IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAN ANY TIME IN ITS
HUNDRED ELEVEN YEAR HISTORY.
FURTHER IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH AT ITS
SECOND MOST PRODUCTIVE YEAR ARE
IN ITS HUNDRED NIGHT HIS. AS
WORKERS LOADED AND UNLOADED-
SEVEN MILLION SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND- T. E. USE
ARE COMPARED WITH THE EIGHT
MILLION. NINE HUNDRED NINE
NINE. EXCUSE ME EIGHT MILLION
NINETY ONE THOUSAND. AND TWENTY
THREE TWO YEARS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. HOWEVER WE MUST ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA SPORTS STAY
COMPETITIVE AND NOT LOSE OUR
MARKET SHARE TO THE EAST COAST
OR GULF COAST PORTS. IN IN OUR
PORTS. DO THAT IF OUR PORTS TO
ATTRACT CARGO OUR WORKFORCE
WILL ON A NEGATIVELY IMPACTED.
A SECOND WAY TO STAY
COMPETITIVE IS BY INSURING THAT
REAL RATES ARE REASONABLE
CURRENTLY IT COST ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE TO MOVE A
CONTAINER- IN THE WEST COAST-
THEN AN EAST COAST AND GULF
COAST. A THIRD WAY TO STAY
COMPETITIVE REQUIRES THE
ENTITIES SUCH AS CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD NOT. OVER
REGULATE OUR PORTS OVER
REGULATION BY CARP INCREASES
THE COST FOR OPERATIONS THAT
ARE PORTS AND MAY IN TURN
DISPLACED WORKERS. YOU CAN BE
DIVERT THE OUR OUR COMMUNITIES
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING JOBS
CURRENTLY CARD. AS A GOAL THAT.
THAT ALL IMPORT ALL THE
EQUIPMENT AT THE PORT SO BE
ZERO OR NEAR ZERO EMISSION.
WHEREAS THE PORTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH WE'VE
ADOPTED THE SAME PETER BASS
CLEAN AIR ACTION PLAN TO REDUCE
POLLUTION. FROM DIFFERENT
SOURCES THE I'LL BE SUPPORTS
OUR COMMUNITY IS BEING BRAIN
HOWEVER WE CANNOT END UP WITH
REGULATIONS THAT WILL LEAVE
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED. CALIFORNIA
CANNOT AFFORD TO SEE
COMMUNITIES LIKE DETROIT OF
THAT WERE DEVASTATED BY UNION
AUTO WORKERS LOSING THEIR JOBS
FARMING I WOULD LIKE THANK YOU
ALL. THE REST OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR CONSISTENTLY
SUPPORTING THE I'LL W. BY
ALLOCATING FUNDS TO THE PORTS
FOR CLEAN EQUIPMENT AND ENSURE
IN. PUBLIC ARE NOT CONSIDERED
PLACE TELEPHONE WORKFORCE.
GOING FOR WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ARTS AND EMPLOYERS AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO STAY COMPETITIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU UP
JUST QUICKLY JUST A QUESTION OR
TWO BOB. FOR A MISTER JACOB YOU
YOU YOU YOU YOU SEE THE VOLUME
MIGHT BE UP OF MIKE ITS MARKET
SHARE MIGHT BE DOWN COULD YOU
JUST EXPLAIN THAT DYNAMIC YEAH
I THINK REYES SPOKE TO A LITTLE
BIT AND BUT IT'S A QUESTION- SO.
OUR OUR UP COMPARED TO WHERE WE
WERE PRE RECESSION. BUT IT'S
TAKEN OVER A DECADE FOR US TO
GET THERE AND IN THE MEANTIME
OUR COMPETITORS HAVE BEEN
GROWING FASTER. SO WE ARE-
HITTING A STRIDE AND I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
PORT DIRECTORS IN THEIR PANEL-
THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD. OF THE
WORK WE DONE TO RICK IN THE
CARGO WE HAVEN'T GROW. AT THE
RATE WE HAVE- BUT- WE HAVEN'T
BEEN REINVESTING IN. PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE OUR
COMPETITORS HAVE WE HADN'T BEEN
RAN- IN INVESTING IN TAX
CREDITS FOR. SHOULD BE XIN
CENTERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
UP. STREAM THAT ATTRACT MORE
CARGO FASTER- LIKE SOME OF OUR
COMPETITORS STATES HAVE- AND IT
IT IT'S A CHALLENGE- AND SO YOU
KNOW WE DO HAVE A DICHOTOMY.
WHERE YES WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT WE'RE STILL
GROWING- BUT WE ARE GROWING AS
FAST AS WE NEED TO CATCH UP.
WITH BOTH OUR INTERESTS. GO
THANK YOU MISTER FROM ARE YOU
YOU YOU YOU ALLUDED TO OTHER
STATES OR MAYBE ANOTHER STATE
ADOPTING SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIKE REGULATIONS AND I
REGULATIONS CAN BE GOOD BUT NO
SONGS ARE COUPLED WITH
INNOVATION WE CAN'T JUST
REGULATE WE NEED TO INNOVATE
AND WE'VE DONE A LOT OF THAT
REPORTS COMPLEX IF YOU WANT TO
SEE A THING THAT'S HAPPENED. ON
OF TOP TO BOTTOM GO TO THE PORT.
ALL HAVE THEIR IN SPECIFICALLY-
WE TALK ABOUT GOOD WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT TRUCKS. OUR WHAT IT WHAT
ARE OTHER STATES DOING ON THE
TRUCKING FINER THEY TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL OR THEY ALL I MEAN THEY
WERE NOT THERE ON THE ELECTRIC
FRONT YEAH WE WERE GOING TO GET
THERE I THINK. BUT THE WE THE
WAY WE SHOULD ALLOW OTHER
ALLERGIES TO DEVELOP OR
WHATEVER OTHER STATES DOING
ALONG IF YOU JUST. SURE NO
OTHER STATE HAS ADOPTED.
ANYTHING CLOSE THE CALIFORNIA'S
PORTFOLIO OF ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS THE TOP PART THAT I
WAS ACTUALLY REFERRING TO WAS
SEATTLE TACOMA. WHICH DID
TRAIL- THE PORTS OF LA AND LONG
BEACH BY SEVEN YEARS ON THE
BANNING OF PRE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TRUCKS. OTHER STATES. YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS SORT OF
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
DONE WELL CALIFORNIA DOES. A
PUT. STATE FOR. SOURCES TOWARDS
PILOTS IN THEM. NATION YOUR
MISSION. AND THAT WE ALL. ARE A
HAPPY ACRE. ON CERTAIN ASPECTS
OF OUR POLICIES. SUCH AS-
GETTING UTILITY INVESTMENT IN.
CHARGING STRUCTURE. OFFER
TRANSPORTATION. AND HOWEVER
MOST OTHER STATES ARE TAKING
MORE OF A- YOU KNOW THE- CARE.
THE STATE PRO. WITH ITS INDUCED.
ALL IS WHERE A- I THINK THE
SICK IS. VERY RAPIDLY. CHAIN
MORE. BUT THESE AREAS YOU KNOW
AND I. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT WOULD BENEFIT- THE SYSTEM
AS A WHOLE IS KEEPING IN- IN
AYE TOWARDS THE PLACES WHERE
THIS TECHNOLOGY WITH WHAT IT
CAN DO TODAY. AND WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN ELECTRIC
CHARGING AND JUST GOING UP TO A
FUELINGSTATION TO GET A TAKE A
DIESEL- MEAN AND IF WE CAN
CONCENTRATE TIME AND EFFORTS IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKS- WORKS TO DEAD. RECIPE
FOR SUCCESS AND NOT CHIU
HORNADY AND IN- THE STREET IT'S
NOT QUITE READY. THANK THANK
YOU AND I. PRESENT YOU YOU. YOU
IT IS. SAID AND YOU. YOU WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T CREATE
GREEN POVERTY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA MY REGULATING THESE
INDUSTRIES OUT. AND THEY HAVE
TO MOVE TO ANOTHER STATE AND
ALL THE JOBS MIGHT BE THERE AND
I THINK YOU. YOU YOU LET ARE
TRIED IS BEING SAMPLE OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPENING
IN IN IN IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY. REALLY AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT SOME INVESTMENTS IN
TRAINING COULD YOU COULD YOU.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
YES- INVESTMENT IN TRAINING
RIGHT NOW AS THE TECHNOLOGIES
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED IT'S
IMPORTANT WE BRING THE WORK
FORCE TO THE FUTURE. AND NOT.
SLOWLY WE NEED TO RAPIDLY AS
QUICKLY AS THIS INDUSTRY. NEEDS
TO CHANGE- I MENTION CARB. OF
CARBS OF GOAL OF A ZERO
EMISSION OR NEAR ZERO. BY
TWENTY THIRTY- WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN WE SEE WITH
THE INDUSTRY'S DOING BUT IN THE
MEANTIME. I'VE GOT COMING
OPERATORS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
TALKING WITH PMSA IN A- OPTICAL
INDUSTRY. ABOUT A WEEK. HYBRID
NOW. WE CAN GET OUR TWO JEEZ IN
THE EIGHT PER. FOR ME. TODAY
AND THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO.
CAPITAL IN EQUIPMENT THE THAT.
ISN'T GONNA. BENEFITS. WHERE
THE DOT MICHAEL IN YEARS
BETWEEN NOW TWENTY THIRTY WE
GOT SO MUCH WORK TO DO BUT WHAT
CAN DO IT AND STILL. ARE RETAIN
JOE AND CLEAN THE- BUT WE'RE
GONNA NEED CARBON OTHER FOLKS
TO. PROBABLY BE- I HAVE A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING TODAY. THANK YOU. SIR IS
THIS FIRST DID YOU HAVE ANY.
THE ONE THING THAT I'VE BEEN
READING A LOT ABOUT IS THIS
AUTOMATION IN THE PORTS. AND IT
IS OF GREAT CONCERN ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
WORKERS- CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT TO THAT MR FAMILY.
AUTOMATION'S AVAILABLE THERE'S
A HUGE COST A HUGE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES THE ONLY REASON-
YOU'VE GOT THE LARGEST TERMINAL
OPERATOR IN THE PORTS OF LA
LONG BEACH. AUTOMATING RIGHT
NOW IS BECAUSE THEY HAD DEEP
POCKETS THERE THE LARGER
SHIPPING COMPANY IN THE WORLD
MASK. THEY WROTE A LARGE CHECK-
THE OTHER- STEVEDORE. COMPANIES
TERMINAL OPERATORS MANY DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES AT
THIS TIME TO AUTOMATE THAT'S
WHY EVERYONE'S LOOKING.
CONSCIOUS OF MY LABOR FORCE
WHEN I HEAR THE TRUCKERS TALK
ABOUT TRUCK TURN TIMES AND
MOVING THE GOODS TO MARKET WE
KNOW WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS BUT IN THE SAME
TIME. NOT EVERYBODY- IN THE
INDUSTRY HAS THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES- TO INVEST IN
AUTOMATION AND I BELIEVE THAT-
A LITTLE BIT OF TECHNOLOGY CAN
GO A LONG WAY IN IMPROVING. OF
THE- IS THAT WE NEED TO IMPROVE
IN RIGHT NOW AND I THINK IF I
MAY JUST JUMP IN ONE OF THE
THINGS AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
FROM THE STATE LAW. IS AT WE-
THAT. THAT TIME SO. YOU'RE A
REGULATORY AGENCIES PICK A
TECHNOLOGY IN OTHER WORDS
THEY'RE NOT TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL.
FOR EXAMPLE LECTURE VACATION
LECTURE OCCASION CAN OFTEN MEAN
AUTOMATION. AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE NEED TO BE VERY COGNIZANT OF
THESTATE LEVEL THAT WE'RE
CREATING WISE POLICYTHAT IS
TYPICALLY TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL SO
THAT INNOVATION CAN HAPPEN ON
THE GROUND WE CAN MOVE. YOU
KNOW IF WE CAN BE AS- LEAST.
MOVED SO THAT THAT'S ONE OF
THINGS WE PUSHING EVEN FOR
STRONG A STRONG VOICE ON THE
AUTOMATION FRIEND DOWN OF THE
PORT A LEVEL DOWN THE SPEED OF
YOUR WORKFORCE QUITE FRANKLY
YES YES THAT'S RIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH THAT
YOU ARE SPEAKING FOR YOUR
WORKFORCE THE COMMENT THAT YOU
MADE WE MUST ALWAYS AT THE
RIGHT TIMES IT ALL. UP TO MAKE
THE JOB. IT THAT WE- IN. BEING
ALONG ONE OF A ONBOARD NOW
THAT'S AND NOT NOT WARDEN YEAH
WITH NO HOW WE DIDN'T IT
ABSOLUTELY SO THANK YOU ALL
CHEN WHEN THANK YOU VERY WELL
THE ENGINE WITH YOU THINK. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT AND THE
ONLY TO OUR NEXT PAN WHICH IS
THE CHAIR. TO PORTS AND GOODS.
IN THE COMING DECADE THAT PANEL
IS MADE UP OF. MARLON FLOOR
NóI ADD TO TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING PROGRAM DIVISION CHIEF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION FRANK ROMERO HIS
MANAGER GOODS MOVEMENT AND
STANDING FREIGHT UNIT. FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT- THANK
YOU GENTLEMAN FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. AND I KNOW HERE IN NEW
JERSEY FOR IT EITHER WAY YOU
JUST MET EACH OTHER SO- THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY WERE TO
START WITH. MR FLORIDA OKAY
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND SETTLING
MEMBERS ON I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO TODAY TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT. CALTRANS ROLE IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS COMPETITIVE
IN THE UPCOMING DECADE. OF THE
GUIDING. VISION INFLUENCING-
THE FREIGHTS USTAINABILITY AND
CALIFORNIA'S DERIVE FROM THREE
PERSPECTIVES- THE FIRST IS
ECONOMIC VITALITY.
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP. AND
SOCIAL EQUITY. OUR ROLE IS TO
PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO KEEP THE GETS MOVING
UNTIL REACHES THE CONSUMER.
CALTRANS ALSO COORDINATES
POLICIES AND STRATEGIES TO
CREATE A MORE INNOVATIVE
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE AND
MULTIMODAL FREIGHT NETWORK-
EVERY FIVE YEARS CALTRANS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY UP
STE UPDATES THE POLICIES AND
STRATEGIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
FREE MOBILITY PLAN THAT CHARTS
THE- TRUE OF GOODS. MEANT THE
CALIFORNIA FREE MOBILITY PLANET
TO COMPREHENSIVE DOCUMENT. THAT
THE PLANS FOR THE IMMEDIATE AND
THE LONG TERM- PLANNING
ACTIVITIES AND CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS WITH SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A DRAFT PLAN THROUGH
AN EXTENSIVE ENGAGEMENT OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING THE FREIGHT- INDUSTRY
WORKSHOPS HELD ACROSS THE
STATE. ARE NUMEROUS WORKING
SESSIONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FREIGHT ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AND
THE ENGAGEMENT OF THE PORTS. WE
ALSO- CURRENTLY ARE- HAVING OUR
TO OUR DOCUMENT OUT FOR PUBLIC
REVIEW. OF THE DRAFT INCLUDE
SEVEN GOALS DEVELOP THROUGH AN
EXTENSIVE OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THE FIRST IS
SAFETY WHICH IS CALTRANS NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY. A FURTHER WE AIM
TO STRATEGICALLY INVEST IN
MODERNIZING THE MULTIMODAL
FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
WITH INNOVATIVE APPROACHES SUCH
AS LEVERAGING. ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVING THEY
ARE RELIABILITY OF TRAVEL
TIMES. WE ALSO LOOK TO GROW THE
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS OF
CALIFORNIA STRAIGHT SECTOR BY
INVESTING AND FREE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. I TO
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY. WE
SUPPORT STRATEGIES THAT REDUCE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE OF
FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM-
AS WE DO THIS WE AIM TO ENHANCE
COMMUNITY HEALTH BY ADDRESSING
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF FREIGHT
RELATED PROJECTS AND
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO NEED TO
MAINTAIN AND PRESERVE OUR
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
FINALLY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES AND
IMPROVING FREIGHT- SYSTEM
CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL FREIGHT
MODES. TO IMPROVE TO SUPPORT
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THESE
GOALS THE FREE MOBILITY PLAN-
PROPOSES SPECIFIC OBJECTIVES
AND STRATEGIES INCLUDING
IDENTIFYING AND INCENTIVES FOR
LOGISTICS INDUSTRY.
IMPLEMENTING STRATEGIES TO
OPTIMIZE THE FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AS WELL
AS PROVIDE RELIABLE TRAVEL
TIMES ESTABLISHING STANDARDS
ARE TO ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF THE
FREIGHT MOVEMENT ON COMMUNITIES
IN IMPLEMENTING STATE OF THE
ART- CHEST IS HE EXCUSE ME
IMPLEMENTING STATE OF THE ART
TECHNOLOGY TO CREATE
EFFICIENCIES. ADDITIONALLY SAY
AGENCIES HAVE A CRITICAL ROLE
TO PLAY IN TERMS OF
CONSTRUCTING OPERATING AND
MAINTAINING MANY FREIGHT
FACILITIES TO ADDRESS OUR
LIABILITIES OF THESE FACILITIES
THE FREIGHT MOBILITY PLAN
INCLUDES REGIONAL INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES THAT INCLUDE
IDENTIFYING KIßM CINEMA
CONTEST FREIGHT CORRIDORS. AND
EIGHT AND ARE EXPANDING A
FREIGHT TRAVEL INFORMATION
AVAILABILITY TO THE PARKING
COMMUNITY BY PROVIDING REAL
TIME DATA. THE FRIEDMAN PLAN
ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL
STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE SAFETY
THE TRUCK PARKING POSITIVE
TRAIN CONTROL UPGRADING EDGES.
SCREENING CARGO. NOT LIKE TO
TALK TO YOU BRIEFLY SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE PHRAS
FACING THE FREIGHT SECTOR IN
THE UPCOMING DECADE. LET ME
BEGIN WITH HOW THE FREIGHT
SECTOR COMPETES PORTS COMPETE
FOR CONTAINER TRAFFIC TO ACCESS
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. AND THE
REGION'S COMPETE FOR
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS WHICH
AFFECTS CONTAINER TRAFFIC AT
THE PORTS. FOR CALIFORNIA PORTS
ARE SEEN INCREASES IN TENER
VOLUMES. GROWTH AT THE- EAST
COAST GULF AND THE CANADIAN
PORTS IS OUTPACING CALIFORNIA'S
GROW THEIR MANY FACTORS FOR
THIS INCLUDING THE PANAMA CANAL
EXT EXPANSION. INCREASED USE OF
THE SUEZ CANAL. OF THE COST IN
OF LAND AND LABOR IN CALIFORNIA
AND CENTERS OFFER BY OTHER
STATE GOVERNMENTS TRUCK PARKING
SURCHARGES ALSO IMPACT WORKING
HOURS FOR TRUCKERS TO HELP
ALLEVIATE TRUCK PARKING ISSUES
CALTRANS IS BEGINNING A
STATEWIDE TRUCK PARKING STUDY.
WHILE THERE SEEM TO BE A LOT OF
HIS WITH KEEPING PORTS AND
GOODS MOVING COMPETITIVE THERE
ARE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES TO
OPTIMIZE THE GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SB ONE. TRANSACTION
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY OR TAKING A BALANCED
APPROACH. WE CAN BE COMPETITIVE
AND GREENER WITHOUT ADVERSELY
AFFECTING. OUR IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES. WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
RESPONSIBLE FOR ABOUT 40% OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS RELATED TO DIESEL
EMISSIONS WE MUST MAKE FREIGHT
MOVEMENT MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
LESS IMPACTFUL TO SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES WHILE MAKING THE
FREIGHT INDUSTRY EVEN MORE
COMPETITIVE. THIS CAN BE DONE
WITH GOVERNMENT INCENTIVES AND
FUNDING IMPROVE FACILITY
DESIGNED TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS AND PACE.
COLLABORATING ON LOGISTICS AND
OTHER METHODS THERE'S SEVERAL
FEDERAL AND STATE OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH BEACH THREE QUARTER HAS
BEEN PROGRAM WHICH IS COMPRISED
OF SB THREE QUARTER HAS BEEN
FUNDS AS WELL AS FEDERAL
DISCRETIONARY. FUNDS FORCES
FUNDING AND- SB SOLUTIONS FOR
CAN COURT. ADDITIONALLY WE ALL
FUND AND STUDIES THROUGH THE SB
ONE SUSTAINABLE- TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING GRANT PROGRAM WHERE WE
ENCOURAGE INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIP BASED
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS YOU
THESE PROGRAMS THE STATE SENATE
SUCCESS TRANSPORTATION PUTTING
THE COLT CROSSING A GREAT STEP
PROJECT TEN BERNIE NO COUNTY.
THE STATE ROUTE FIFTY SEVEN AND
SIXTY CONFORMANCE OF PROJECT
IMPROVEMENTS THE LA ALAMEDA
RAIL CORRIDOR AND FOR PORTRAYAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN INTELLIGENT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS THE HELP
PLAN ORGANIZE AND ARRANGE THE
TRANSPORTATION OF GOODS TO IN
FRONT PORTS AND OPENS UP.
FAURIA IN CALLED THE NASH WAY
FOR INTERNET TRADE AND DOMESTIC
COMMERCE CALIFORNIA EXAMPLE THE
WORLD'S MOST INNOVATIVE AND
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE
MULTIMODAL FREIGHT NETWORK WE
PRIORITIZE SAFETY. RESILIENCY
RELIABILITY AND SUSTAINABILITY
AND WE EQUALLY CONSIDER THE
ECONOMIC COMBAT COMPETITIVENESS
SOCIAL EQUITY AND BAR MALL AND
TAX WHETHER MANY CHALLENGES
THERE EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES
RICH AND CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS
A NATIONAL LEADER IN. DUE TO A
LARGE PART THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS MADE TO BE ONE.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE PLANS AND TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
SPEAKER WITH IMMERSIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAU DONALD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS FRANK TO MEET US I AM
THE MANAGER OF THE GOODS
MOVEMENT AND SUSTAINABLE
FREIGHT UNIT AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
GULBIS. GO VISIT THE STATE'S
LEAGUE- JOB GROWTH AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS AND WE
PROVIDE SUPPORT DIRECTLY TO
BUSINESSES IN THE STREETS WE
ALSO COLLABORATE AND LAID ON
pINITIATIVES THAT ADVANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIES INCLUDING
PROGRAMS LIKE THE FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION. AND THE REASONS
RISE TOGETHER INITIATE. HOW
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS IN THE
MIDST OF A HISTORIC ECONOMIC
EXPANSION. WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND OF RECORD JOB GROWTH WITH
WITH A HUNDRED NINETEEN MONTHS
OF EXPANSION. CALIFORNIA IS A
TOP US STATE FOR TWO WAY TRADE
AND EXPORTS OF TEXTILES WOULD
PETROLEUM CHEMICALS PLASTICS
MACHINERY AND MORE. WE ARE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY AN
AGRICULTURAL FOOD BEVERAGES
APPAREL AND MORE. THIS WOULD
NOT BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
EXTENSIVE GOODS MOVEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDED THROUGH
OUR ELEVEN PUBLIC PUBLIC PARTS
TWELVE CARGO CARRYING AIRPORT.
EARLY FIFTY THOUSAND LANE MILES
OF PAVED. FIVE THOUSAND MILES
OF FREIGHT ROUTE ROUTE RAIL
TRACKING. WHEREVER TIED TO OUR
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND
DOMESTIC COMMERCE LOGISTICS
FREIGHT WHERE HOUSING AT THE
COMMERCE INDUSTRIES HAVE
DEVELOPED WITH THE SCALE THAT
IS UNMATCHED IN THE COUNTRY. AN
ESTIMATED FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION JOBS IN THE STATE ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
INDUSTRIES. GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS LIKE DOCKWORKERS WAREHOUSE
AND RAIL WORKERS TRUCK DRIVERS
TRADE SPECIALISTS FARMERS
MANUFACTURERS BANKERS PILOTS
AND AIRCRAFT MAINTENANCE
WORKERS. THESE JOBS ARE
CRITICAL COMPONENTS OF OUR
OVERALL ECONOMIC SUCCESS AS A
STATE. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
GOVERNOR BROWN ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER BE THIRTY TWO FIFTEEN
WHICH RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND THE
NEED TO DEVELOP A STATE LEVEL
INTEGRATED FREIGHT ACTION PLAN.
GOBIZ AND SEVERAL OTHER
AGENCIES WERE DIRECTED TO
DEVELOP THE SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT
ACTION PLAN AND IDENTIFY STATE
POLICIES. PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS THE CHIEF THE GOALS
OF IMPROVING FREIGHT EFFICIENCY
TRANSITIONING TO ZERO MISSION
TECHNOLOGIES AND INCREASING THE
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT SYSTEM.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND BOB IS
COMPLETED THE ACTION PLAN. AND
RECEIVE THE PROVIDE THE
GOVERNOR THE PLAN IDENTIFIED
OVER SEVENTY SPECIFIC STATE
AGENCY ACTIONS. OUR OFFICE
UNDERTOOK ACTIONS RELATED TO
INCREASING THE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS. MARKETING THE
ST STE FREIGHT INDUSTRY. AT
ADDRESSING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TIED TO THIS
ASSEMBLY FOR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. WHILE THE ACTIONS OF
THE SYSTEM OF PRODUCTION
PLANNER STILL BEING EXECUTED BY
THE VARIOUS AGENCIES. I WILL
SHARE BRIEFLY SOME OF THE WORK
BEING DONE BY GOBIZ. OUR OFFICE
DEVELOP THE WORKING GROUP
COMPRISED OF PUBLIC. AND
PRIVATE STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP
IDENTIFY DATA NEEDS DEVELOP
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS TARGET
AND METRICS AND PROVIDE
EXPERTISE FROM THE BOTTOM UP
PERSPECTIVE. GOBIZ ALSO
PARTNERED WITH RESEARCHERS FROM
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES TO HELP
FOR PERFORMED THE DATA DRIVEN
COMPONENTS OF THE ACTION ITEMS
INCLUDING MAPPING WORK FOR
SKILLS AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CRITICAL
SYSTEM AFRAID OCCUPATIONS
ACROSS TRANSPORTATION
CONSTRUCTION AND MANUFACTURING
SECTORS SECTORS. AS THEY RELATE
TO FREIGHT. WE'RE ALSO DRAFTING
A STRATEGIC MARKETING PROGRAM
AND CAMPAIGN TO PROMOTE THE
STATE'S FREIGHT TRANSPORT
SYSTEM CAPABILITIES
ACHIEVEMENTS AND LEVERAGE OUR
LOCATION AND IN THE COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE. WE HAVE IDENTIFIED A
MODEL THAT WILL BE PILOTED TO
ADVANCE THE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS GOAL THE MODEL
WILL MEASURE THE IMPACT OF
STATE REGULATIONS AND POLICIES
ON THE ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS
OF THE STATE'S FREIGHT INDUSTRY.
IN THE WORK FORCE AREA WE
IDENTIFY THE- TOP TWENTY
MISSION CRITICAL OCCUPATIONS TO
ELEVATE THE NEXT DECADE AND
HAVE DEVELOPED A PILOT
WORKFORCE TRAINING CONCEPT. YOU
EXISTING. PIPELINES AND LOCAL
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS. GOBIZ
WILL CONTINUE ITS WRK TO
SUPPORT THE FREIGHT TRANSPORT
SYSTEM IN CLOSE CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE GROWING
OUR TRADE AND EXPORT FOOTPRINT.
PARTICULARLY AS TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCED OUR ABILITY TO
MINIMIZE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT.
BUSINESSES AND INVESTORS ARE IN
NEED OF STABILITY AND STRATEGIC
APPROACHES TO CHRONIC
CHALLENGES AND EMERGING
OPPORTUNITIES. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CALTRANS NOTED WELL
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
THE WAY CALIFORNIA FACES
CHALLENGES EXPORT MARKET SHARE
HAS DECLINED IN COMPARISON TO
STATES LIKE LOUISIANA TEXAS
ILLINOIS LEBRON THEIR EXPORTS
IN DOLLAR VALUE FASTER THAN
CALIFORNIA. STATES LIKE TEXAS
LOUISIANA QUESTION IN SOUTH
CAROLINA AND GEORGIA NOT TO
MENTION BRITISH COLUMBIA HAVE
TAKEN TRADE VOLUME FROM
CALIFORNIA PORTS WHILE
INCREASING THEIR INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HAVING LOWER
PROCESSING COSTS. ALL THIS
DESPITE CALIFORNIA CONTINUING
TO MAINTAIN THE LARGEST PARK
COMPLEX IN THE COUNTRY.
ENTERING THESE MARKET REALITIES
CALIFORNIA MOST PRIORITIZE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE OUR PORTS AIRPORTS
RAILWAYS ROADS AND LOCAL
TRANSPORT SYSTEMS REMAIN
COMPETITIVE. SIMPLY PUT
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AND TRADE
INVESTMENT IN OUR CAPABLE GOODS
MOVEMENT SYSTEM. ISN'T A GIVEN
STATE POLICY NEEDS TO SUPPORT
ITS LONG TERM ECONOMIC
COMPETITOR. WE MUST MAINTAIN
PROPER ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIA. ONE THAT IS
MEASURED BY GROWTH AND
INCLUSION ONE THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE 4299% OF THE JOBS
IN THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON. THE NEED TO
REMAIN ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE
AT IREMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF OUR PROPOSALS I MEAN
WHAT COULD SEE THEY WERE ALL
THE WAREHOUSES ARE JUST BE ON
THE CALIFORNIA BORDER. RIGHT SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
WERE WERE CREATING WISE POLICY
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THINGS LIKE
FACILITY CAP OTHER MANDATES
THAT. THAT'S OUR OUR OUR OUR
MOVEMENT IS MY- HERE TO EYES.
I'M THE ONES SO WITH THAT- DID
YOU WISH TO SHARE ANYTHING ELSE
GENERAL. NO NO THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU AGAIN APPRECIATE
THAT THE FOCUS ON ACADEMIC
COMPETITORS VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE STRUCTURE
DOLLARS NEED TO BE. PUT IN
PLACE TO. REMAIN ON TOP SO
THANK YOU. WITH THAT WILL GO TO
OUR NEXT PANEL- HOW THE PORTS
ARE RISING TO THE CHALLENGE AND
THE STATE'S ROLE. AND WE'LL
HAVE COME FORWARD- MARIO
CORDERO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH. AND
KRISTIN DAVIS- CEO AND DIRECTOR
THE PORTAL I NEED ME. AND JEFF
WINFIELD- DIRECTOR OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS FROM THE PORT OF
STOCKTON. AND I PPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A HORSE
STOCKTON HERE BECAUSE I SEE
MARIO IN TOWN I KNOW HIM. THE
CHRISTIAN SUMMER SO OFTEN BUT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR MORE FROM
STOCKTON. OKAY CURRENT.
HONESTLY I JUST YOU KNOW I KNOW
WHY HE'S BEEN VERY ENGAGE THE
PORT ISSUE SO AS THE LA AND
LONG BEFORE WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM STOP AND WE NEED TO HEAR
FROM WEST SACRAMENTO WE NEED TO
HEAR FROM FROM FROM SAN DIEGO
AS WELL I DON'T CAP WAS- SOME
PLANS OF THE BILL ON THE STATE
GETS RUNNING AS ROBERT THING
THAT EVERYBODY'S. ARE
PARTICIPATING TO ALTER OVER
TOMORROW I WAS THE EXECUTIVE IS
THAT WHO'S GONNA GO FIRST MARIO
OKAY. I THINK THE ORDERS. OKAY
MY MARK FUTURE OKAY YOU MAY GO
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIR
AND LIKE THE THANK MEMBERS AND
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE OF. THE
THING THIS AFTERNOON REGARDING
COMPETITIVE IN THE NEXT DECADE
IS VERY UPPER POLL PARTICULARLY
IN THIS PARTICULARLY IN THIS
POINT IN TIME AS MY- THE PRIOR
SPEAKERS HAVE COMMENTED. FOR
LONG BEACH WE ARE THE GREEN
PORT. AND THE SECOND BUSIEST
PORT IN THE UNITED STATES ALONG
WITH LOS ANGELES HAS BEEN
REFERENCE THIS IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST SUPPORT COMPLEX. FOR
THE POOR LONG BEACH WE MOVE A
PUNCH ME TO HUNDRED BILLION
WORTH OF CARGO EACH YEAR. LET
ME TAKE OVER SOME TIME PERIOD
NOTE A COUPLE OF OUR
ACHIEVEMENTS ONE AS HAS BEEN
REFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE
PORTS. AND WITH A BIG PLAYER
THEY ARE IN JOB PRODUCTION.
HERE AT THE POOR LONG BEACH- WE
LOOK AT THE STATE LEVEL. UGH
JOBS THAT COME FROM THE PORT
OPERATIONS. DIRECTOR INDIRECT
SUPERSEDE SEVEN HUNDRED FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS YOUR TONGUE BUT
IT INDUSTRY THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT JOB PRODUCER. WITH
THAT THERE'S ANOTHER GREAT
ACHIEVEMENT THAT WE'VE DONE AS
PORTS. AND THAT IS BY WAY OF
OUR CLEAN AIR ACTION PLAN WHICH
COMMITS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX. AND THAT CLEAN AIR ACTION
PLAN RESULTED AND MORE PERSONAL
TACKLED THE HARMFUL EMISSIONS
FROM POOR OPERATIONS AND WHAT
THAT RESULTED IS AN 87%
DECREASE IN PARTICULAR MATTER.
50% DECREASE IN NOT. AND 97%
REDUCTION AND SOCKS. THAT'S THE
TREMENDOUS QUESTS THAT THIS
INDUSTRY NEW SPORTS HAVE DONE.
GOING FORWARD WE NOW HAVE THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CLEANER ACTION
PLAN. AND THE PORTS ARE
CONTINUING WITH THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP WE'RE
NOT JUST REDUCING EMISSIONS OUR
QUEST NOW IS TO E. RATHER KATE
EMISSIONS WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS
ZERO EMISSION CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT. AND ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS. WITH REGARD TO THE
FORMER THAT'S TWENTY THIRTY IN
A TO THE TRUCK TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY THAT'S TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE WE DID THIS BY WAY OF
COLLABORATING WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE PORT
COMPLEX TRUCKERS MARINE
TERMINAL OPERATORS. SHIPPERS
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPERS AND I
GIVE THIS BACKGROUND. BECAUSE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PORTS WHO HAS SPENT
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS IN CORPORATE
RESPONSIBLE CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACCOMPLISH A
MANDATE THAT NO OTHER POOR
COMPLEX INDEED ON THE STATE'S
HAS EVEN ATTEMPTED TO ACHIEVE.
NOW LET ME. OUR MARKET SHARE
ISSUE. AS WAS REFERENCE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING THE
GOVERNOR INDICATED THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST INVEST IN OUR
COMPETITIVENESS AGAIN I CANNOT
STRESS ENOUGH TO THIS COMMITTEE
HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. THE COMPETITION
IS GULF AN EAST COAST PORTS.
AND AS YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN THE
RESPECTIVE GRASS AND CHARTS UP
WE'RE LOSING MARKET SHARE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PORTS. YOU
KNOW I MENTIONED LOS CHALLENGES
NUMBER ONE LAW WHICH IS NUMBER
TWO. NEW YORK NEW JERSEY IS
RIGHT ON OUR HEELS. OF SO I
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HOW TO BE ADDRESS IS
COMPOSED OF ISSUE WHICH I
BELIEVE. AND I CANNOT STRESS
ENOUGH THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO NEEDS TO
CHIME IN ON THIS QUESTION
BECAUSE WE DO NEED YOUR HELP.
THIS IS NOT JUST AN ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE COMPETITORS AS A
RESULT OF. THEIR MANY FACTORS
BEST NOT JUST BECAUSE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN DC IN RELATION TO
THE TRADE WAR. THE IT'S NOT
GUARD TO OTHER ASPECTS THAT THE
OF COME INTO PLAY IN THE MOST
RECENT ONE OF COURSE THE- CROWN
OF OURS. ENTER THE WHAT THAT
IMPACT MAY HELP ON THE SUPPLY
CHAIN. OF GOING FORWARD. LOTUS
IS ALSO WITHIN THE CONTROL OF
THE PORTS AND WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE. BUT AGAIN I CAN'T
STRESS ENOUGH HOW IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. WE DO KNOW THAT BECAUSE
OF THE LEADERSHIP IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND A LOT OF THAT IS DEPENDENT
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE'RE
BIG PLAYER INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
SO WITH THAT. I THINK THE
ACTION THAT WE ARE. THE
REQUESTED OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO BRING THAT DIALOGUE FORWARD
AT THE HIGHER STATE LEVEL- IN A
WAY IN WHICH AGAIN. COULD HELP
ADDRESS THESE FACTORS SOME OF
THESE FACTORS HAVE BEEN ALREADY
REFERENCE JUST FROM OUR
RESPECTIVE HERE- SPEAKING FOR A
POOR LONG BEACH AND POOR LOS
ANGELES. YOU KNOW WE ARE
PLACING GREAT EFFORTS WITH
REGARD TO OUR SERVICE. OUR
COSTS. AND ALSO AGAIN YET A
DYNAMIC WITH REGARD TO THE LOSS
OF MARKET SHARE IS THE
INCREMENTAL MOVEMENT OF CARGO.
MANUFACTURING IT IS FROM CHINA
THE SOUTHEAST ASIAN. IT ALSO
WITH THE WHAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
ABOUT OF A FACTOR HERE OR
FACTORS IS WHAT ARE OTHER
COMPETITORS HAVE DONE ARE THE
PORES NEW YORK NEW JERSEY
VIRGINIA SAVANNAH. A HOUSTON
AND A CHARLESTON. THESE ARE ALL
PORTS WHO HAD INVESTED OF.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT AND OF
COURSE THE POLITICAL WILL
BEHIND THAT IT THIS MEANT. IS
VERY STRONG SO SUFFICE IT UP
FOR CALIFORNIA. I THINK WE ARE
IN INFECTION POINT WITH REGARD
TO OUR COMPETE. TERMS OF THIS
INDUSTRY ME TO THE STATE. NOW
SOME OF OUR CHALLENGES. LET ME
RESPECTFULLY THAT I THINK ONE
OF OUR CHALLENGES IS REGULATION
IN THE STATE MORE SPECIFICALLY
WHAT'S WHAT WE SEE AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD.
OF THE BOARD- AND I SAY THIS AS
A PIONEER POOR LONG BEACH AND
LOS ANGELES WE ARE PIONEERS IN
TERMS OF STATEMENT ABOUT. SHORE
PARTY WE'VE INVESTED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WITH REGARD TO SHORE
POWER TECHNOLOGY. HOWEVER AT
THIS POINT. HARPER IS INTENDING
TO MOVE WITH A PROPOSED RULE TO
FURTHER LIMIT AT BIRTH
EMISSIONS WITH REGARD TO OF OIL
TANKERS AND RURAL VESSELS IN
WHICH THE TECHNOLOGY THERE IS
NOT HERE TO DO THIS AT A POINT
IN THE TIMELINE THAT CARP WHICH
TO DO SO. AND THUS I WOULD ASK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE ASK
OURSELVES THE QUESTION OR AXIS
OF THE QUESTION WHETHER WE
COULD UP THE LADY THE CARD TO
PLAY REGULATION ANOTHER TWO
YEARS OF THE YEARS THAT WORK IN
ABOUT HIS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY SEVEN THAT TO BE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY NINE WITH
THE GUARD AGAIN TO THAT'S IT
IMPACTS WILL ROLL VESSELS AND
OIL TANKERS SO SUFFICE TO SAY
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY WITH REGARD
TO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AT
ALBERT'S EMISSIONS THERE. IS
NOT IS NOT AVAILABLE NOW THERE
ARE A COUPLE ENTITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN CERTIFIED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT AGAIN IN TERMS OF
WHETHER THEIR MARKET A
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE AT THIS
POINT THE ANSWER IS NO. SO THIS
IS RATHER CHALLENGING BECAUSE
AGAIN WITH REGARD TO THE MANY
OTHER FACTORS IN TERMS OF. WHAT
THIS STATE REGULATORY AND MAY
BE DOING TO SUPPORT OUR THEORY
MISSION QUEST IN FACT. HAS A
HINDRANCE WITH REGARD TO OUR
COMPETITIVE A CHALLENGES HERE
AS PORTS IN THE STATE. WELL WE
CERTAINLY WANT APPRECIATE WHAT
THE STATE HAS DONE WITH REGARD
TO CAP AND TRADE AND WE
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE THAT THE
PORCH PLACE A PRIORITY WITH
REGARD TO THE FUNDS
NECESSITATED TO MOVE FOR WITH
OUR ZERO EMISSION GOAL. A
SECOND ANOTHER ISSUE THAT AGAIN
HAS A POSITIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
FOOTPRINT IS OUR INVESTMENT ON
TALK RADIO SO WE KINDLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
FURTHER FUNDING BE WRECKED TO
SPECIFICALLY TO RAIL SERVICE
MOVE CONTAINERS. OF A RAIL. AND
I WILL SAY THAT THE TRUCKING
WILL ALWAYS BE A COMPONENT IN
THIS MOVEMENT OF GOOD. BUT THE
MORE WE PUT ON RAIL THE MORE
EFFICIENT WE BECOME AND AGAIN
ANOTHER GOAL TERMS ARE TO CITY.
POLLUTION FOOTPRINT. A
WORKFORCE HAS BEEN RUN ALREADY
HAVE. AGAIN I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
PARTICULARLY IN THE TIME THAT
WE'RE MOVING. MORE TOWARDS-
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IF. WE DON'T
TAKE OF A GOOD LOOK AT HOW WE
DO THIS AND IMPLEMENT FUNDING
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IS
GOING TO IMPACT JOBS IN THE
STATE. AND IN THE LONG TERM
AGAIN WE ALL KNOW THE WHOLE
QUESTION ABOUT ROBOTICS. AND
AUTOMATION IN TERMS OF. A THIS
IS MOVING IN OUR GLOBAL. BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND AGAIN WE NEED TO
THE AGAIN INVEST IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SO AT LEAST WE CAN
HELP. AND PROTECT THAT JAR
MARKET OF THE FUTURE. OF. HOLLY
WE DONE THIS AT THE PORT TO
ADDRESS THE MARKET SHARE- JUST
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO I GAVE THE
STATE REPORT HERE TO POOR LONG
BEACH AND FOR ME I SEE THIS AS
THE YEAR OF COLLABORATION AND
YOU'RE ALREADY SEEING THAT
COOPERATION AND IS THE COURSE
WITH THE WORLD RULES THE UNIONS
WITH MANAGEMENT AND HERE IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE PORTS
ARE LIKE THE COLLABORATORS TO
THE CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS. JUST
A COMPETITIVE. WHICH I IS SOME
ECONOMY BUT TO. LET'S MOVE A
VERY. WAY IN TERMS OF HOW BE
ACCOMPLISHED AS SHE REMISSION
GOAL WHICH AGAIN I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THESE TWO PORTS ARE
ABSOLUTELY ON BOARD IN TERMS OF
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE. TO
ADDRESS THE HARMFUL EMISSIONS
AND MOVE TOWARD ZERO. AND I
DON'T WANT TO GET RID OF IT BUT
THERE IS NO OTHER INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE. THAT HAS A RESUME IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO TO SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASE
HARMFUL EMISSIONS MORE POOR
OPERATIONS. UP SO AS I CLOSE
HERE I WANT TO. AGAIN THANK
GOAL IS ANOTHER OF THE UNIT SO
OF THE GOAT OFFICE IN TERMS OF
EFFORTS. HEARD OUR PRIOR
SPEAKER HERE ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE. OF WE ARE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT WORKING WITH GOAL BILLS
TURN TO THIS QUEST TO ADDRESS
COMPETITIVENESS. AND WITH THAT
I WILL CLOSE AT THIS TIME IN
TERMS OF MY COMMENTS BUT AGAIN
I JUST WANT TO STRESS HOW
IMPORTANT IS THE COMPETITIVE
ATMOSPHERE HERE. IN REGARD TO
THE PORTS AND THIS IS NOT
UNLIKE THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ACTION PLAN A MISTER CHAIRMAN
WHICH YOU ARE VERY MUCH PART OF
THAT IN TERMS OF. THE POLITICAL
WILL URGING LONG BEACH TO
AFFORD WITH THAT KIND OF PLAN
OF ACTION NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE SHIPPERS HAVE CHOICES. AND
IF WE DON'T TO MOVE IN A
PRAGMATIC- I'M AFRAID TO SAY
THOSE CHOICES WILL MOVE AGAINST
THE INTERESTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WILL IMPACT OUR
ECONOMY. AND OF COURSE BACK
JOBS HERE IN THE STATE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU JUST JUMP OFF THAT LAST
POINT. AND THAT WILL FLY IN THE
FACE OR COMPETITION MENTALLY.
IF THEY GOT OTHER STATES IN
OTHER REGIONS AND DON'T HAVE
THE GREEN. FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM RICK. AND WE HAVE ON. OUR
ON ON THE ON THE ON THE GOOD
MOVE IN INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT WILL GO TO MYSTIC
US. FROM THE POOR WHITE ANY.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN- AS I
SIT UP HERE AND REPRESENTS THE
PART WHEN HE ME BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO FAIR TO THAT AT I
COULD SAY THAT I REPRESENT ALSO
THE PART OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
OTHER CALIFORNIA PARTIR BUT WE
SHARE THE NICHE MARKET OF
AUTOMOTIVE. AND A FRESH PRODUCE
AND A SUPPLY CHAIN COACHING
CARGOES MOVE THROUGH OUR PORTS.
JUST KIND OF FROM A HIGH LEVEL
VIEW THE PORT ECONOMY WHEN THE
ME MUCH LIKE YOU HEARD HERE
FROM MARIO I THINK YOU'LL SEE
CONSISTENT THREAD WE REALLY ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES WERE THE FOURTH
LARGEST EMPLOYER. IN VENTURA
COUNTY WE MOVE NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN CARGO SUPPORT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND JOBS AND
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OF THOSE
ARE DROPPED JOBS- SO IF YOU
LOOK AT ME LIKE OXNARD WHERE
YOU HAVE. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND THEY ARE THOUSAND
SET LIPS COME TO WORK. CLEARLY
WERE IMPORTANT THAT. IT'S FACE.
ANY PERSON. DAY AND LOOK OUT.
GOOD BOB. THE STATE JOB BECAUSE
AT THE PORTS THE ARE THE TYPES
OF JOBS THAT WE CREATE TAPE
AVERAGE OF BROKE JOB AB AROUND
SEVENTY DOLLARS A YEAR SO THESE
ARE PAYING AND VERY POOR TARA
KHAN ME WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT I THINK
WE'LL HEAR FROM ALL OF US ARE
COLLECTIVELY A VOICE ON PORTS
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS. REPORTED WHEN HE
ME IS JOINED A PROGRAM CALLED
DURING MARINE WHICH IS A THIRD
PARTY VALIDATOR COMES IN AND
AUDITS ARE PORT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT JUST PUTTING
HERSELF IN THE BACK AND TELLING
OUR GREEN AS RATIONALLY HAVING
SOMETHING LIKE AN ENERGY STAR
COME IN. AND TELL US HOW WE
THAT TESTED WE GET CERTIFIED IN
THAT YEAR OVER YEAR WE GET
VOTED AT THE GREEN SHIPPING
SUMMIT AS THE NUMBER ONE THREE
IMPORTANT A COP FOR YOUR VERY
PROUD OF THAT ACCOLADE BUT
WE'RE ALL UP THERE DOING THESE
SORTS OF THINGS WE ALSO GOT
SOME SENSE OF MONEY WERE INVEST
IN THAT. ELECTION CALL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT OUR PART.
BUILDING G. MANAGEMENT PLAN AT
MUCH LIKE LA LAW TO OPEN
ANOTHER PORTS WERE BUILDING A
CLEAN AIR PLAN DIRECT
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR ON AIR
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD. THE PORT
ARE JUST SANTEE. AND WHEN WE
ARE VERY. ABOUT THE NEXT
ITERATION OF THE- GUIDELINES CA
THROUGH A R. B. BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLICATIONS ON ROW ROW AND THE
COMPETITIVENESS THEY ARE- IF
YOU LOOK AT ROBO FLEETS THEY
TEND TO CONSIST OF AS MANY AS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SHIPS THE
GOING. GLOBAL TRADE LANES AND
ARE GONNA. FIT A HUNDRED FIFTY
SHIPS AT THE TUNE OF A MILLION
DOLLARS PER SHIP TO FOLLOW. ME
RICH IN SAN DIEGO SO. WE'RE ALL
AGAINST AS WE LOOK AT THESE
REGULATIONS COMING INTO PLAY
AND HOW IT IMPACTS OUR OVERALL
COMBAT IT COMPETITIVENESS. ON
THAT SAID. BASED ON WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'VE HEARD US IS
THAT WE ARE ALL AND WE WANTED
TO THE GREEN THING WE'RE
WILLING TO DO IT BUT WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING IN A WAY THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE AND FEASIBLE. AND
SO I'M NOT NAY REITERATE THE
GOOD POINTS THAT MARIO MADE BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT AT THE POLICY LEVEL WHERE I
THINK THAT THE STATE COULD DO
SOME THINGS THAT COULD. HELP
THE DIFFERENCE ON. IN ONE SUCH
AREA THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT
POWER. SO WE'RE MOVING TO THE
ZERO MISSION ECONOMY. DO YOU
REALLY HAVE THE POWER LOCALLY
TO SUPPORT THAT ZERO MISSION
ECONOMY WELL WE'VE BEEN ASKED
AND PASSED BY OUR LOCAL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
COMPANY UTILITY COMPANY TO PAY
DO CONDUCT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR STUDY. SEE IF
THEY CAN MEET. THE OUR MANDATE
OF A. R. B. AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S FAIR TO PUT THAT ON THE
BACKBONE OF THE PORTS. FOR US
TO FIGURE OUT IF THE STATE HAS
SUFFICIENT POWER TO FUEL- THIS
MOVEMENT TWO ZERO EMISSION SO
HOW CAN WE AT THE STATE LEVEL
KIND OF DO SOME SORT OF
ASSESSMENT. WE HAVE WHAT WE
NEED AT THE UTILITY LEVEL DO
ALL THESE. ON IN IN ZERO
EMISSION MANDATES ON THE PORT
SYSTEM FROM WHAT WE KNOW AT THE
VERY ONSET OF OUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH SOUTH SEVEN CALIBER.
CALIFORNIA EDISON WE MAY HAVE
TO INVEST AS MUCH AS SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS JUST FOR THE
NEXT. ITERATION OF THE
GUIDELINES SO THIS IS A VERY
REAL ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT IN HOW WE ARE GOING TO.
REALLY COME UP WITH THE POWER
WE DON'T CREATE BLACK AT ALL
THROUGHOUT BEEN TORE COUNTY
BECAUSE- OF EMISSION REDUCTIONS
AT THE PORT SO THERE HAS TO BE-
CONVERSATION THERE ARE WE
REALLY NEED TO BRING THE
UTILITY. COMPANIES AND ALSO
WANT TO JUST QUICKLY ON THE
TERRACE. I'M RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
THIS STATION A PORTABLE GAMING.
AND WE HAVE POWER COMES IN THEY
ALL LET US USE THAT. FOR
PLUGGING IN. SHORT SIDE POWER.
SO WE'D LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
REGULATORS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
IS HOW COULD WE GET. SOME
FLEXIBILITY INTO THE CPUC TERRA
TO USE THAT POWER FROM
SUBSTATIONS FOR OTHER THINGS-
WE HAVE A CRANE RIGHT NOW THAT
WE CAN'T PLUGIN. BECAUSE OF THE
TARIFF ISSUE ELECTRIC GREEN AND
ELECTRIC CRANES SO IT'S RUNNING
ON DIESEL NOW BUT IF WE COULD
AMEND THE CHERUB SO WE COULD
USE. THE POWER OF THAT
SUBSTATION I IT WOULD GO A LONG
WAY AND THERE ARE ALSO ISSUES
OF THE CPC TARIFF RATES AND
THAT ONCE YOU SO MUCH. AS YOU
IN THESE EGREGIOUS. SO THEN CAN
WE WORK WITH OUR LOCAL
REGULATORS C. P. YOU SEE THAT
THE UTILITY COMPANIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THE FEES ARE FAIR
AND THAT WE CAN USE POWER THAT
WE HAVE- AVAILABLE FOR EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES AND THEN MAKE SURE
DOWN THE ROAD AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH WITH ALL THESE MANDATES
WE DID HAVE ENOUGH. POWER TO
FEEL WHAT IS BEING ASKED OF US.
ARMED AND THEN- ONE OTHER AREA
WERE ALL PLAYING FOR GRANTS YOU
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS YOU KNOW WITH THE-
BONNET TECHNOLOGY I THINK YOU
WERE SPEAKING TO THAT'S NOT
VERIFIED FOR THE ROW ROW. WELL
WE'RE STILL GOING TO ASK FOR
THESE GRANTS BECAUSE IT'S
EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IF THERE'S SOME
WAY THE STATE COULD HELP WITH
TODAY YEAH. YOU'RE GOING. TO DO
THESE. SO YOU COULD HELP US
MAKE OUR GRANTS COMPATIBLE FOR
FEDERAL FUNDING. I THINK THAT
WOULD GO AWAY LONG WAY LIKE THE
EPA DEAR GRANTS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE VERIFY TECHNOLOGY WILL
THEY WON'T EVEN CONSIDER.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WERE PUSHING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT VERIFIED SO IF
THERE'S SOME WAY TO. MARRY UP
WITH THE FEDS ARE ASKING FOR
AND WITH THE MANDATES ARE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY AWESOME AT. AXIS
FEDERAL FUNDING I THINK THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL IN THE
POLICY DISCUSSION WE CAN HAVE
THE STATE LEVEL. AND THEN
FINALLY JUST AS WE'RE LOOKING
AT EMPLOYEE AND- TING A VARIETY
OF RULES AND DRIVE. INS AT
PERTH REGULATIONS CARGO HIT ME
QUIT AND ALLEGE. STRATEGIC MUNY
ELATION HARPER CRAP
REGULATIONS. OF THINGS ARE
MOVING AT THIS TIME IT FOR AN
INTERNAL CONVERSATION AT A OR
B. T MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
ALL COHESIVE IN ON PAGE NOT.
IT'S NOT THE YOU KNOW THAT THE-
SOUP IS WHAT IS STUPID THREE.
WORKING AND IT TASTES GOOD TO
GET ALL THE INGREDIENTS IN
THESE RULE MAKING SO THAT THERE
CAN. GO HE SAID THAT MAKES
SENSE. BECAUSE FROM EXPERIENCE
I THINK THE PORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN REGULATED WE CAN TELL YOU.
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS EVEN A
CHALLENGE. BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
THE SUREST POWER SYSTEMS- ONLY
HAVE ONE MANUFACTURE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IT HAS ONE MECHANIC.
AND WROTE FIGHTING OVER
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THEY
FIXED YET WERE. HEAVILY
MANDATED SO. I LET'S FIX WHAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE NOW AND MAKE
SURE IS THESE RULE MAKINGS ARE
IN THE PIPELINE THAT. THIS CALL
HE- YES AND- IT'S ALL. EXCEPT
SPEAK FROM A TECHNOLOGY
STANDPOINT EMPOWER STANDPOINT
AT. ROOMMATE STANDPOINT. AND
WITH THAT COMMA. I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP I'M NOT CUT COMING
UP YOU'RE QUITE BUT JUST TO
HAVE HONEST DISCUSSION. ABOUT
THE CHANGES THAT WE CAN MAKE.
TO MAKE SURE WE BONTA. MONEY
THAT FELT PORTS OUR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK GLAD TO
BE AT THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY
TO SAYS FIVE YOU. JUST TO ALL
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ON
THE TO STOCK IT ALL THE PORTS
FILL CERTAIN NICHES AND WITH
PORTER STOCKTON WE ARE A BALKAN
BREAKABLE PORT. UNLIKE THE
OTHERS YOU SEE HERE TODAY WE
DON'T HAVE CONTAINERS AT OUR
FACILITY WE SPECIALIZE IN
BUILDING MATERIALS SUCH AS
CEMENT AND STEEL. AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS SUCH AS DRY AND LIQUID
FERTILIZERS AND AS WELL AS WE
EXPORT CALIFORNIA RICE ALL OVER
THE GLOBE. OVER THE PAST YEARS
WE'VE AVERAGED APPROXIMATELY
FOUR MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CARGO. AND WE SAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
VESSEL CALLS PER YEAR. THAT MAY
NOT BE A LOT IN TERMS OF THE
VOLUME COMPARED WITH A THREE
PORTS ARE TOP REPORTS OF LA
LONG BEACH IN OAKLAND. BUT FOR
STOCKTON AND SAN JOAQUIN AREA
THAT'S TREMENDOUS AND SPECIALLY
THIS IT'S THE THERE'S BEEN HIT
HARD ECONOMICALLY AND- WE
SUPPORT OVER TEN THOUSAND GOOD
FAMILY WAGE PAYING JOBS IN THAT
AREA WHICH- ALLOWED TO BE
CONSIDERED THE TOP THREE THREE
JOB PROVIDERS FOR THAT AREA.
CURRENTLY OP ON TWO THOUSAND
ACRES AFTER ACQUIRING OF ROUGH
AND READY ISLAND FROM THE NAVY
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE- IF
YOU'VE DRIVEN BY THE PORT ON I
FIVE YOU PROBABLY SEE A VERY
SMALL SLIVER AND SO WE'D
WELCOME ANYBODY. THAT'S TO COME
BY WILL SHOW YOU ALL THE- THE
BACK PORTIONS AND- THE MANY
ACRES AND A LOT OF THE GREAT
THINGS THAT WE ARE THAT WE ARE
DOING THEIR- SOME OF OUR
BIGGEST CHOP. THE COMPETITIVE
IN THE NEXT DECADE AND I DON'T
WANT TO SOUND REDUNDANT SO I'LL
START OFF WITH SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT AND THAT
IS- MAINTENANCE DREDGING- A-
LOT OF THE PORTS. IN THE BAY
AREA RELY ON MAINTENANCE
DREDGING TO BE EFFICIENT AND TO
MOVE GOODS- THE WAY WE NEED TO
MR HARBOR MAINE INSTAX. THE
ISSUER. IT'S SO THE HARBOR
MAINTENANCE TAXES SUPPOSED TO
GO BACK INTO A FUND THAT
SUPPORTS MAINTENANCE DREDGING
SUPPOSED TO IT'S SUPPOSED TO
MUCH LIKE THE GAS TAX WE DON'T
SEE A LOT OF IT COMING BACK TO-
TO THE DONOR STATES IN. AND
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
CONVERSATION BUT- BUT WHAT WE
WOULD BE USED TO DREDGE THAT-
THAT WOULD BE FUNDING FROM
THAT- FROM THAT. FUND WOULD
WOULD COME BACK TO US TO BE
ABLE TO DREDGE BUT IT'S NOT
JUST THE FUNDING IS TO RIGHT
NOW FUNDING IS. WE'RE GETTING A
LOT RELIABILITY AND PER AND AS
WELL AS FUNDING AND SOME YEARS
IS REALLY ARE OUR BIGGEST
ISSUE- OUR CHANNELS OFFER
AUTHORIZED TO THIRTY FIVE FEET
DEEP. AN OFTEN WE OPERATE. AT
MINUS THIRTY TWO FEET. FOR WEST
SACRAMENTO THEIR AUTHORIZED IN
TO MINUS THIRTY FEET MANY TIMES
THERE AUTHOR OTHER OPERATING IN
THIRTY OR TWENTY SEVEN FEET OF
WATER. WORKING WITH THE CORPS
OF ENGINEERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THEIR CONTRACTORS IN
THE WATER BETWEEN AUGUST FIRST
TO NOVEMBER THIRTIETH EVERY
YEAR IS IT IS A CHALLENGE FOR
US AND WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
STATE AND WE GOT SOME DREDGING
FUNDING THROUGH SB ONE A COUPLE
YEARS AGO- TO DREDGE WHAT WE
CONSIDER THE LOCAL SERVICE AREA
AND WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL AND WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO DANCE TO
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU MORE
ABOUT ABOUT FILLING IN AND
POTENTIALLY WORKING WITH THE
WITH US TO ASSIST WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT.
EITHER GET THERE WITH FUNDING
OR RELIABILITY. AS AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE. ANOTHER
UPCOMING REGULATION THE AT
BIRTH REGULATION IS A BIG
CONCERN FOR US- YOU KNOW. WE
HAVE ALL PUBLIC BIRTHS WE DON'T
HAVE TERMINAL OPERATORS AND SO
THE PORT ITSELF WILL BEAR TE
COST TO PLACE THESE. BONTA
SYSTEMS BECAUSE WE ALSO WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO PLUG IN
ANY THE VESSELS THAT COME TO
THE PORT OF STOCKTON THESE ARE
TRAPPED VESSELS THAT COME. IN A
ONE TWO THREE TIMES A YEAR AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENT TO. INSTALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR SHORE
POWER. SO THEN WE'RE LEFT WITH
THE BONNET SYSTEM THAT'S THERE
SO WE WOULD HAVE TO CONFIGURE
ALL OF OUR BIRTHS WITH THIS
BONNET SYSTEM. AND OUR CHANNELS
NARAL SO WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE A BARGE THAT
CAN MOVE AROUND AND SO. THE
INVESTMENT IS SIGNIFICANT AND
WITH. YOU KNOW WITH. THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S THERE. WERE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THAT'S GOING TO DO OUR
BUSINESS- RIGHT NOW JUST IN THE
BACK OF A BACK A ENVELOPE THE
COST THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ARE.
MORE THAN TEN ARE WHARFAGE
COSTS AND- SO WE REALLY SEE-THAT AS DRIVING BUSINESS OUT OF
THE STATE- PORTS THAT OUR OUR-
BUSINESS THAT COULD COME TO
STOCKTON WOULD SEE YOU KNOW
PROBABLY THE- PACIFIC NORTHWEST
OR- FOR. POTENTIALLY CAN'T TO.
I'M I GREW UP IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAYOS DISTRICT AND USED
TO RIDE MY BIKE ALL DAY FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. NUMBER TO DENY
ONE WOULD COME HOME RIGHT WITH
LUNGS IN. AND SO I CAN FULLY
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE DOING TO
REDUCE- EMISSIONS AND- TO
IMPACT THESE COMMUNITIES. OCT
AND- IN COLLABORATION WITH PORT
ALONG AND THE OF WE SOME. A
XANDER OF GRANT THIS PAST YEAR.
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING. AND UTILIZING
THIRTY FIVE ZERO MISSION CARGO
HANDLING- PIECES OF EQUIPMENT-
ALONG THE PORT. AND WHILE THIS
IS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTING- AND UTILIZING
THIS EQUIPMENT. IT WOULD NOT OF
BEEN DOABLE IF WE HADN'T
PARTNERED WITH. LOW OAKLAND AND
LONG BEACH A LOT OF THE GRANT
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS FOR FIFTY
FIFTY MATCH FOR THE LOCAL-
STAKEHOLDERS. AND BECAUSE THE-
SWISS. IS THE LEAD I THINK. OUR
MATCH TO TWENTY. WHICH WAS
ENOUGH TO GET OUR BOARD TO BUY
IN IN INVEST AND FINALLY JUMP
INTO THE ZERO MISSION- GOALS.
AND SO WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE THAT
THAT'S IT'S SUCCESSFUL WE'VE
JUST STARTED RECEIVING OUR
EQUIPMENT VERY- EXCITED ABOUT
IT WE'RE GONNA BRING SOME OF IT
UP I THINK. LATER IN MARCH TO
DO A SHOWCASE UP HERE CAP WELL-
BUT- MAYBE THE POTENTIAL FOR
THE STATE TO LOOK AT REDUCING
SOME OF THOSE. THIS CALL SHARES
MAULER MEET SIZE POOR WOULD BE
A LOT MORE OR A- OF. FOR PORTS
LIKE STOPPED IN A OTHERS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY.
CLEARLY LAW MY NOTES SO. I
WOULD JUST THE THANK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M TO BE. WE
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL SEE MORE OF A
AT THE TIME IN READY TO GO SEE
YOU YOU CAN COME SEE US INTO
AND SO THANK YOU AND IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS AJ I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OKAY AND THAT THE YOU
COVER A LOT THERE- THEIR THEIR
THEIR- POWER THE PLUG IN WITH.
THAT BUT BUT THEN IT I'LL TURN
TECHNOLOGIES ON IT THE BONNET
WHICH IS IN A BONTA ANYMORE
RIGHT BUT IT THAT'S WHAT THE
PEOPLE KNOW IT AS RIGHT THE
SOCK WHATEVER THE LABEL TALK SO
IS THAT IS THAT CARP APPROVED.
IT'S NOT A PER CARB APPROVED I
THOUGHT IT WAS. IT'S NOT
VERIFIED BUT SO CAN YOU CAN BE
USED AT BIRTH AND IS IT MEET
ANY REGULATE ANY REQUIREMENTS
STILL IT'S STILL A PILOT PHASE.
CARP HAS SERVE HAS CERTIFIED OF
THESE ONE OF THE ENTITIES THAT
I'M AWARE OF OKAY- IN I THINK
BUT THE ACTUAL. READING THIS OF
THAT PARTICULAR ENTITY IN TERMS
OF COMING MARKET TO ME DO YOU
LIVE ON THE MARKET MARKET
AVAILABILITY. THAT'S THAT'S
STILL CHALLENGE. BECAUSE I
THINK A BIG DEAL HERE IS THAT
THE IT'S YOUR WAY YOU'RE FACING
IN YOUR DAYS IN YOU IN YOUR
PORT IS THE INFREQUENT CALLERS.
AS A MEMBERSHIP A COMMUNIST AND
THREE MILLION BUCKS OR WHATEVER
IT'S GONNA COST ME TO CONVERT
OVER TO PUT SHORE POWER WHEN
I'M IN CALIFORNIA I GO IN THERE
ONCE- GET THE VERIFY. A HAS
BEEN THE IN WATER SYSTEM AND
THAT'S WHAT ALLEN ON BEACH TO
USE BECAUSE THEIR BIG PORTS BUT
STOCKTON AND WHEN YOU MEET
DON'T HAVE THE IN THE- TURNING
BEACON IN THE SIZE AND THE WAY
IT FOR THEY IN THE WATER SYSTEM
SO. TO GO TO WHAT'S CALLED AN
EIGHT AND WENT AND TECHNOLOGY
IS A COULD YOU USED. WHETHER
YOU'RE OVER THE THAT WHAT'S.
OUR AND ISN'T VERIFY. IT AND
THE WORKING THROUGH AND WE'RE
TALKING TO A COP. IT'S WILL TO
TEST. OUT WHEN EMAIL. AND THEN
WE WENT TO LOOK FOR DEAR MY-
FOR A- THAT TECHNOLOGY DEAR
SAYS. CAN'T BE IT'S NOT. SO
THERE THERE ARE SYSTEMS OUT
THERE IN DEVELOPMENT THE ONE
HE'S REFERENCES AND KRAMER
ACTUALLY READY BUT THERE'S
ALSO. THAT'S JUST NOT A- RETURN
FOR THE SMALLER PORT. EITHER SO
IT'S- IT'S STILL VERY IMAGE.
AND GROWING INDUSTRY AND
PRIVATE TALK ABOUT IT YOU KNOW
DELAYS AND REGULATIONS THAT WE
HAVE TIME TO CATCH UP WITH
WITH. YOU KNOW THE R. AND D.
AND ALL THAT. SO WITH REGARD TO
THE ROWERS THE ROLL OFFS. WITH
THAT POTENTIALLY BE A
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD BE THIS
WITH THEM. THAT WOULDN'T MOST
LIKELY HAVE TO. ACKNOWLEDGE IT
BECAUSE FOR ONE IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO RETROFIT ROW RUSH
GETS FOR PER SIDE. OUR THESE.
AN HAS OF THE SIZE OF THE PLEA.
IS TO NOW. A CALL. EFFECTIVE SO
YOU HAVE TO. THAT OKAY. YES
THERE. AND THEN. QUESTION I
THINK. BUT I KNOW LOTS OF OIL
ON ELECTRICITY MIGHT NOT BE A
GOOD IDEA. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS- IT. THERE'S BEEN
SOME COMMUNICATION AROUND HERE
ABOUT POTENTIALLY MAYBE THE AG
MAYBE SOMEBODY TO DO IT NEEDS
TO DO A FEASIBILITY. STUDY
BEFORE CARP JUST ESTABLISHES A
REGULATION I THINK THERE'S AN
INDUSTRY MEMBER HERE WHO WANTED
TO SPEAK TO THAT. I DON'T KNOW
IF MARGO'S HERE NOT. I DON'T
SEE THEM BUT- THERE SHE HAS DID
YOU DID YOU WISH TO PUT THE LID
ON. ON THAT TOPIC OF IT. JUST
IDENTIFY YOURSELF ANSWER YET
THANK YOU SO MUCH MARGO PARKS
AND A HALF OF WITH BY- WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION AT
YOUR QUESTION AND- MISTER
DONNELLY BELIEVE THAT. YOU KNOW
WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF THE
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS ON THIS
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AS WAS DISCUSSED
THERE'S- THERE ARE SOME
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE IN. PILOT
STAGES THAT HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED BUT THAT IS ON THE- ON
THE CARGO SIDE AS I UNDERSTAND
IT NOT ON THE TANKER SIDE. AS
YOU POINTED OUT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES- WITH PLUGGING IN A
TANKER- INTO A INTO A TERMINAL.
THERE'S ALSO WHICH IS WITH THE
AND THE SOCCER THE SENATE
SYSTEM THAT HAVE YET BEEN
WORKED OUT IT'S PREMATURE
ACTION IS POINT EVEN TO DO THE
TYPE OF. YOUR I'D- HE UM LIKE
PILOT DEVON JUST BE WE HAVEN'T
EVEN DONE THE RISK ASSESSMENT
I'M ON THAT TECHNOLOGY AS THE
LAST THING I THINK THAT ANYONE
WANTS IS TO HAVE A PILOT
PROJECT OR OR MUCH LESS A SHIP
COME AND PUT A SOCK ON THEIR
OVER THE BOILER AND HAVE AN
EXPLOSION OF IT IN A PART
SEVERAL NIGHTMARE. THERE ARE
MANY STE IT HAPPEN. TECH CAN BE
USED ARE A LOT OF INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO THIS TYPE
OF REGULATION SETTING- AND
TESTING SO WE ENCOURAGE ON A
ARE BEING WE'VE SPOKEN WITH
THEM AT LENGTH AND I KNOW WITH
THE PORTS OF YOU KNOW GETTING
THE RIGHT STATE. OUT THE TO
ASSESS HOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
ASSESSING THIS TECHNOLOGY IS A-
POINT. EVEN AS A- AS YOU WISH.
TO STUDY THE FEASIBILITY.
BEFORE A REGULATIONS ESTABLISH
IS THAT CORRECT ABSOLUTELY I
THINK OUR PRIMARY CONCERN HERE
SAFETY- AND YOU KNOW AS THE
PORTS POINTED OUT I THINK THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN MEET THE GOALS A
RB HAS. AND WERE- WERE VERY
EAGER TO WORK WITH AIR BE ON
THAT AND YOU KNOW AT THIS POINT
USING THOSE TECHNOLOGIES MAY
NOT BE THE BEST. BEST PATH
FORWARD BUT PERHAPS THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES. TO GETTING THESE
EMISSIONS REDUCTION BEYOND WHAT
THE PARTS OF ALREADY DONE WITH
THIS TREMENDOUS. X. BUT THANK
YOU OUR SPEAKERS TO YOU WISH TO
ADD ANYTHING THE I JUST WANT TO
ADD ONE MORE. IN EMPHASIZE
RESEARCHER IN SOMETHING YOU
SAID THAT I THINK IS VERY
RELEVANT TO THIS DISCUSSION.
WHICH IS WE NEED TO INNOVATE
NOT REGULATE. AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE PORTS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE BEEN INNOVATORS AGAIN
THERE'S NO INDUSTRYTHAT HAS A
RESUME THAT WE DO. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REPORTS OF BILLION A
PORTS ALONG BEACH WITHIN A
DECADE REDUCED EMISSIONS
HARMFUL EMISSIONS FROM TRUCKS
BY 90% NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
COUNTRY HAS THAT RESUME SO WE
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO
MISTER THAT WE COULD GO TO ZERO
EMISSION BY THE GOAL YOUR THAT
WE'VE INDICATED. SO I THINK ALL
THE US IS THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
ALLOW US TO INNOVATE AND MOVE
FORWARD IN A PRACTICAL MATTER
BECAUSE- IF THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. I THINK THE PRIOR
SPEAKERS OF ALREADY ADDRESSED
THE DIRE SITUATION WE ARE IN
MARKET SHARE COMPETITIVENESS
AND CALIFORNIA'S NOT THE FIFTH.
LARGEST ECONOMY. FOR NO REASON.
ONE OF THE BIG REASONS IS
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A GREAT PORT
ACTIVE COMPLEX HERE. THAT'S
INTERNATIONAL TRADE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THIS ISSUE AS WE GO FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THIS
PANEL THINKING ALL SPEAKERS TO
IRAN FOR PARTICIPATING.
CONVERSATION IT'S NOT OVER FOR
SURE I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S A
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AS WE GO FORWARD
THANK YOU. I HAVE TO DO PUBLIC
COMMENT. OKAY SO IF THERE ARE
ANY V. I. ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO COME FORWARD ODD
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOU ONE MINUTE
PLEASE TO SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE HEARING IN THE
TIME IN YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES- DAVID YOW FROM
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND- YOU
KNOW WHATEVER COMES TO YOU OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
THAT'S THAT'S VITAL TO OUR
SUCCESS BE. THE GOAL THAT WE
HAVE OUR ONE YEAR WITH THE
STATE. FOURTEEN A GO EARLY TO
ADOPT TO SHORE POWER EARLY TO
ADOPT CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FIRST
TO ADOPT AN EMP PURSUE AN MP
WITH THE STATE. IN HERE WE ARE
LOOKING FOR REGULATORY%
COHERENCE WE WANT TO GET TO THE
SAME PLACE BUT WE NEED HELP
GETTING THERE SO WE DON'T HAVE
A COLLISION OF STATE LINE STATE
REGULATION LIKE SEQUEL AND
OTHER THINGS. WE JUST WE WANT
TO GET THERE AT THE END AND WE
PATHWAYS TO DO THAT SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
HERE TODAY AND I'D LIKE NEXT
TIME YOU SEE SOME SAN DIEGO
MEMBERS UP SO THAT'S- AT YOUR
JOB ALRIGHT. HONESTLY THANK YOU
FOR BE HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER CALLING WITH THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES I WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR ASSEMBLING US ALL
TODAY I WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR DOING A TERRIFIC JOB
IN BRINGING US ALL TOGETHER I'M
AND I WANT TO ECHO EVERYTHING
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID IN
TERMS OF THE IMPORTANCE
INDUSTRY. STATE I'M- IMPORTANCE
OF US ALL WORKING TOGETHER SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
IF YOU'RE GONNA SPEAK LINE UP.
THAT WAY WILL KNOW HOW MANY
WE'VE GOT GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ELAINE FORD'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TODAY AND I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE. OTHERS COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE THAT IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- TO INNOVATE
RATHER THAN TO REGULATE AND I
WE ALL SHARE THE SAME GOAL
WHICH IS TO REDUCE AN
INSTRUMENTAL. AND DIRECTOR
COURT ARE REALLY DESCRIBE HOW
AMAZING THE PORTS ARE DOING IN-
AN ANSWER. BUDGET BUT THE KEY
IS WHAT RG DOES TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. RIGHT HI TECH.
CLEANER WATER AND BETTER HOW
MUCH FOR THAT HEARING TODAY AND
FOR THINKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE SPORTS PLAY IN THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER SPEAKERS. WITH THAT
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AGAIN PLEASE USE
MY OFFICE AS A CONDUIT FOR THE
ISSUES YOU'RE FACING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY
SPEAK YOUR OWN MEMBERS BUT ALSO
MY OFFICE KILEY- TO TALK TO
ANYONE BRITISH USING THIS YEAR.
THEIR FIRST ONE OF YOUR-
INDIVIDUAL. YEAH SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU.